e
then we can create the
conversation
so and really Jane saying to me all
through this like we have been dealing
with this
issue for so many
years but the issue that we always were
focused on on was the balance billing
issue y that was that was the primary
issue is that we wanted to get rid of
balance billing
and we were certainly acutely
aware that uh the reason why balance
billing
exists is that the ambulance companies
are not getting enough
reimbursement okay so what's happened in
my mind in terms of what sen Bill 407 is
it comes in and say no we're we don't
care about the balance issue all we care
about is how do we get more money for
the ambulance
companies and so I'm a
little I'm a little put off because we
we the insurance department had the
study committee we talked about even we
talked about legislation and how
important that that study committee was
going to try to get to a resolution and
work on some resolution and and then we
were told there was a Senate bill and
and um evidently the the Senate bill was
hijacked and turned into something much
different when it came to uh this rate
setting thing and the idea that we're
going to rate set is just an anathema to
me I just the idea that we the
legislature are going to start um you
know doing the 320 whatever you know
just just that whole idea is we've never
done that before all I can imagine is
the precent by setting that then
everyone who feels like they're not
getting enough will come running in and
saying you know we want you to rate set
for us so when I I'm going through my
head in terms of where how we get to
where we were and what what was what do
we really want to be doing here okay so
given that the ultimate goal that we
were hoping that that we expected the
legislation to do balance billing is is
still
in cville 407 that to me right out of
the block gives and then and then have
the race setting I I'm I'm really having
a little trouble trying to make that
bill as amended work at all okay um so
my inclination would be to interim study
it okay however let me finish my War
more thought and then I'll take but
however when I was discussing calling
you I talked to you last night and I
guess I'm allowed to say that that it's
not illegally because it just oneon-one
um and I taped it okay right well then
you broke the law you broke the law so
that the issue was that you know that
that's if we were to stay the course
that we thought we were on and which was
that you know how are we G how are we
going to get to that how do we get rid
of the balance bilding how what are
where is that balance billing and
um I it it struck me
that in through the hearing that
ambulance services is is as important
every cities in town as all their other
Municipal Services Fire Department
police what it's just another Municipal
service and that um and theoretically
everybody and I know my town does it you
know every town has money in their
budget for the ambulance service and yes
it is a private you know in in our case
it's a nonprofit but in other cases it's
a private and some cases it's actually
part of the fire department so every
town theoretically could would have
solved the balance billing problem if
they just paid for it yeah raise taxes
no well they would be pay through taxes
but they could pay the balance billing
and that and then and we did hear that
there was a certain town that actually
did that that they don't balance Bill
their residents they just absorb they
just pay for what about the teeny tiny
towns that don't have the population
well they say the teeny tiny town which
I would call My Town you know maybe not
teeny tiny but big we 6,000 people that
we actually our town in in
Jaffrey has a nonprofit ambulance
service between the two towns and we
basically funded we have set us about
800 right so and your and how how does
your Ambulance Service stay flow I
volunteers and it's paid through the
town if you there's a line item in your
town budget for them okay so the issue
came in my mind is so town could solve
this problem by just you know hitting
the taxpayers but the taxpayers probably
don't really want to pay for it and they
probably want that skin in the game they
want the person who called the ambulance
to have some skin in the game to have to
have that co-pay they want that balance
building they want they don't say we
don't want to pay it for all we want
that person to be you know you you call
it because you really need it you
understand the consequence that that
it's got to have to be paid for but some
heart attack you should and you don't
have money you shouldn't call the
ambulance no and I'm saying that that
obviously some towns do pay for it yeah
okay and my understanding is if you had
a heart attack and you know and you're
an inent that yeah they they they'll
write it off they most counts right at
off okay so again now so now I'm off on
this other tangent I'm still dealing the
balance building
issue I'm not even talking about how we
fully
reimburse you know the this you know the
the ambulances to get what they really
need and and and you said to me well the
one thing that that we're intrigued
about with the uh insurance department
amendment was that it had in that
Amendment had this collection system so
we can really find out what is going on
out there so it does seem to me
appropriate that before we Implement a
system where a fee system and before we
do the mon we should actually have real
data on exactly what is the financial
Str of all these different entities what
is going on with the small towns versus
the Big Towns what is really going how
long is that going to take I well so how
what was the time frame in your
Amendment well but but this has gone on
and on and on for years and now we're
saying we need two more years to
evaluate it and that doesn't seem
to work well the only com comment I
would have with that is when you say
gone on and on theoretically they've
been underfunded since I've ever served
on this committee so 30 years so we're
say okay we're going to make it two more
well we're making it two more with the
showing that we're good faith interest
that if we can intervene and do
something about it that we're willing to
try and look at it but at the end of the
day the question is is how many
ambulance companies have gone out of
business because they keep threatening
this guy falling have gone out of
business in my 30 years well I know of
one and Kean and if anybody really wants
to know the true story I happen to have
a little bit of insight on it since uh I
live in jesha county and uh and we we
ended up creating the replacement so we
can talk about that but I at the end of
the day the the struggles that they're
having whatever they're having I think
before we go into the rat setting
business we really need to know exactly
what we're dealing with so are and I
don't mean this in tanistic way are you
proposing that we wait the two years and
not do anything right now so in terms
of in terms of you know that the issue
of balance billing I mean I would like
to say you know let's just ban balance
billing okay um but I
there you really want to have have you I
mean so you're
saying
uh you just want to have a bill that
says Bal we ban I didn't say that I'm
just saying I I'm uncomfortable I don't
know what I mean I'm not gonna I I don't
know what the solution is I'm
uncomfortable saying we're not going to
do anything for two years that's all I'm
saying okay you're you're not too
excited about putting this off you feel
like today's the crisis I think the
where was the crisis you know last two
years ago last year we had the same
crisis hear from represent spear
represent
spear okay putting my engineering hat on
and I'm working with the
numbers what this bill does and as you
pointed out and as I incorrectly asked
the question yesterday I asked a couple
of the folks would the
325 fix your problem and they said Yes
except that I did not ask the right
question the question really
is the only people that would be paying
the
325 are the
8.6% of the insured
population that is under fully insured
that is fully
insured they are the only ones that
would be paying the 325 per. correct all
of the others the over 90% of people
just go on and do whatever they're doing
right now so whatever money losses the
ambulances are facing and I I absolutely
believe that they are facing some big
losses we're we're trying to carve out a
tiny group of people to fix the problem
for everybody
and that's just doesn't even make
mathematical sense and the other part of
that is other under the fully insured we
have the small group Market which could
not possibly afford taking on that kind
of money that kind of uh a four a $4
pmpm is staggering to that group and
they're the only ones that it would that
would be hit with that we have finally
gotten to the point where we are under
6% un insured and let's face it healthc
care is absolutely dependent on being
4.9% we are putting that whole effort at
risk by forcing people to pay more money
just in a small group just in a small
group to try and fix a problem that is
so much bigger than what they handle I
really need we need the information we
absolutely need the information and and
that Summit didn't come out with what we
were hoping it would come out with and
somehow maybe what we need need is a
bill that forces everybody to sit at the
table give us the numbers and let us
work it out that we we absolutely have
to work it out but not the way we're
doing it not not this just shoot in the
dark and and hit a certain small segment
of people and everybody else just gets
to do what they want and let's face it
the biggest chunk of people that are
going to need this bit need ambulance
me and I'm on Medicare so I don't care
that's not gonna help them R
supp yeah so Carrie put on her
engineering hat I put on my Economist
hat last night and I actually gave the
the lead sponsor a call to kind of talk
because I I missed I had to leave early
unfortunately um one of the thing
everything she said I agree with it's
I'm concerned that it falls to a tiny
little piece um when I spoke with the
lead sponsor she said you know other
groups have already come up like the
Medicaid come up a little bit but you
know one of the things that really
concerns me on it
is we're sort of putting this on
autopilot with this law so if we say you
get 325 per of Medicare and then next
year Medicare increases to the point
where they're actually funding it
appropriately it sounds like they're
very much underfunding right now
underpaying does that still go up by
that Delta of 325 per it sounds to me as
I understand the bill that it would and
that should concern all of us because if
we have an that on autopilot and
then Washington does what they should do
which is put more money into Medicare
funding that $4 is going to go up by how
much because now it's going to be 325
per of the much bigger Medicare number
which I don't know maybe Medicare will
go down and the opposite could happen
but but um but the reality of it is is
we need more money coming from the feds
which is primarily what is paying for
Medicare and Medicaid and to have some
sort of autopilot fixed Delta between
what we're paying is is I don't know if
I'm comfortable with that now if there
was some sort of sunset clause which I
know was discussed I don't know what
people's thinking on that if there was a
sunset Clause because we probably would
be okay for a short period of time to
sort of evaluate it if we want to do
something today I could probably get
behind that but the idea that there's a
fixed 325 of Medicare regardless of
whether Medicare is fully funding as
they should or whether or not they're
underfunding
concerns me and concern all of us
because that would really fleece the
people in this fully insured group so
that's that's the part that I'm most
uncomfortable with and I don't know if
anybody thought about it ever was talked
about before I left but or after I left
but that's that was what really stuck in
my brain as I was leaving and thinking
about this last night I agree with you
100% I mean that's what I'm saying about
it's an unfortunate precedent because to
put that number in there in statute you
know you have to takes a year to get it
out or year to change it
so yes representative Peli thank you
thank you I uh Echo the comments that
are have been currently made I am
uncomfortable with the 325 per I'm not
exactly sure how that was derived there
was a much different number from our um
Insurance um Department spokesperson and
I go back to the I mean it really is
black and I go back to the pie chart I
mean the problem is Medicare and
Medicaid and we can you know as Carrie
said you look at the pie chart you
cannot ask this little sliver to try to
make up for the rest of it and my big
concern is that we're putting so much
pressure on small businesses that they
may decide in the future they're not
going to offer health insurance as a
benefit they'll give a a stipend or a
dollar figure to their employees and say
go out on the private market and good
luck so I don't think that we're going
to solve the problem I do want to see
the data because then they you know that
will be able to help us make the best
decisions and I definitely want to see
the the parties come back together and
to try to mandate that they come come
out with a solution or if they don't
then we could maybe put some parameters
in there if they don't this is what the
ramifications or the consequences could
potentially be and maybe we'll start to
get a little bit more movement if we if
they know that there's a Time dat
and uh requirements for coming up with
some answers so thank you thank you for
microphone so everybody at home can hear
you good
morning okay so obviously the concern we
have is how long this is going to take
and you said two years is there any way
we can do it in a shorter period of time
well that's what I was um thinking about
as you were discussing it um it in some
senses um it might um reduce the task we
would still need an outside Actuarial
and accounting firm to be defining the
information that should be collected in
a uniform way collecting that
information and U making sense of it um
uh in a way that will inform the
legislature um and it's possible
um if we actually put in the legislation
um a a timeline deadline for submitting
the financial data for all the ambulance
providers in the state that uh we could
set at less than two years um I in my
mind I I don't know whether it would be
12 months or my mind in terms of you
know that um we need we would need you
know say when we in terms of the
legislative cycle
yes okay so uh that that if we did it
try to get it done for by January of
next year the next legislative cycle
we're not going to get a full Year's
worth of data right I mean let's assume
assume it takes them assume it takes
them uh always looking at data let me
interrupt um just for a second um you're
always looking at
data retrospectively so
past data yeah okay yeah so so is it
possible that that the this accounting
firm get it done in a couple of months
and then we would then be able to uh you
know have ask all the these financial
reporting numbers to be uh turned in by
by uh December 1st so that we could be
ready for the legislative
yeah I think that's theoretically
possible um we also you know there's the
issue of of paying for it and uh the
proposed amendment that we have um
creates a one-time special assessment on
the health carriers to pay for the cost
that I think it would be about a half a
million million we'd have to admit half
a million what half a million did you
much yeah humorize how where does that
how does that how does that work why
would you need so much money just for
the this that's my guess based on on my
own experience Contracting with outside
vendors that are uh have Actuarial
expertise actuaries are are not um sheap
um of course we would use like an RFI
process to get some idea of what um more
accurate price would be this is just you
know my guess so that that's twofold
none of you're getting the information
and then you're getting a a proposal out
of it to tell you what you're going to
recommend yeah because usually when we
do our studies or our mandate studies it
only costs like 20,000 or 40,000 I yeah
but that's because they're using
existing claims data that okay and the
process
here yeah I thought that the that
Medicare was collecting this this data
Would we not would you as an official
Department have access to that data
already no uh but we do have access to
the uh data reporting template uh that
they
use
no right to know um but it might not
help that much because they're not
surveying every single ambulance
provider in New Hampshire they they're
doing selected providers nationally so
my thought was that the vendor would
probably use their template but then
send it out to every ambulance provider
in the state um yeah and that's the you
know difficult process but I'm sorry
isn't that data already in our database
that we had a presentation on a while
ago it's not part of the claims data the
cost information yeah is not part of the
claims
you yeah so the more I think about it I
do I do think we could operate on if if
it's a more limited task and we could
operate on um a tighter time frame it
probably would cost less than the dollar
um but
well have to go to
finance and I assume that will be the
question that Finance is gonna want to
ask is what is it going to cost
yeah
right okay that if we if if the goal is
to collect that data if we turn this
bill into amend the bill to collecting
this data
um and having the department U have uh a
proposal ready for us for next
January the inter
understood um I don't think it's interim
study because the the whole if I
understand we need legislative Authority
you need legislative authority to do
this so we would need to amend this Bill
Amend the Bill Amend the bill to put in
this study I could do it today if that's
what you have to uh you do it
that so the bill would be turned into
just a you know collect the data collect
the data with the intent of having
legislation for for January is it
possible that we get the parties back
together and mandate that they we can't
mandate the parties to talk to each
other no come up with something we're
kind of starting to like each other
anyway so I don't think it'll be that
hard I know they still sitting in the
separate sides of the
room gu well right Mr
chair Mr chairman yes yeah I know
representative M Miku was here this
morning and he was talking about as well
that first of all he said that the data
for the 350 came from other states that
they've done used in other states was
not a number that's been picked out of a
hat but he also one of his
recommendations as well was that maybe
what we should do to to work on this
problem now is to pass the bill that's
here with a sunset provision to it and
we could also um put not only a sunset
provision but also put a requirement
that this study take place as well so
that way there we the twoyear period
that could allow them to get more time I
he but I'm I'm reluctant to do give and
then take it then might and and and take
it away so that's why that's not a good
that I know I'm the one who offered it
up I said but maybe we should Sunset it
I mean I know I offered it up but I I I
i' I've had plenty of Sleepless hours
tonight to decide last night to say
realize that that's that's not a good I
think the other part of that was that
you quoted a number of four pm PM yeah
$447 that's a lot of money to put on
this tiny little group while we're
waiting for the twoe two uh years to
Sunset and I'm not prepared to risk our
uh uninsured rate for that money you
you've hit the nail
on on the nail on the head I agree with
you absolutely that that is a I mean I
if I were even R to do it I would not
certainly do it the 325 number I mean
that just I mean I I would take I would
take the the Department's numbers at
least which was scaled based upon the
two different the three different areas
and I i' take that um and but again that
would be it's incremental but I I what
really got me when I was thinking about
this last night I was say is that this
is not a new issue I mean we have been
talking about
the but it was always why Balan billing
exists and to have them come in with
that bill with balance building still
there to me that's a slap in the face I
mean that was really you here we are we
one task we asked them to work on and
come out with is like how to get rid of
balanced billing and all they can come
back is we just pay us more money and
don't sweat the balance billing and that
that's not right that's not right
okay how do people feel this is a straw
vote how do people feel with this
proposal of of having an Department come
up with a narrow uh language to just
focus in on the getting this the data
and have legislation ready for next year
as much as I hate to do this I agree
with
some okay does anybody have uh any
opposition ition to that okay because we
open thank you Chris Day W was Halls New
Hampshire um appreciate the opportunity
to
ask if you are excuse me if you are
going to make that Amendment yes I would
just want to make sure that number one
excuse me the direct pay remains because
that's a really important piece what is
the what do you mean by direct um part
of part of this bill compels the
insurers to direct pay oh yeah well we
already passed it y we already passed
that okay so to me that's that's the
whole reason why I was this legislation
my in my mind we should just interrup
stud it because we've already done
something huge Yep this year and I agree
with with the study you know that um I
would also ask that we make sure that
the services continue to have the
ability to balance bill while that study
is underway we are not there's no
balance we're not Banning balance
billing yet I just want to make make
sure that those two elements are still
in there because that's really important
but I I cannot emphasize enough that
until you come back with a bill that has
that bands balance Belling we're it's
going to fall on deaf ears for some of
us on this committee i i i and and you
know my position um we want to get rid
of balance billing absolutely but we
also want to make sure that that was our
singular singular task
it wasn't we are going to get there
subsidizing all the ambulance it was our
singular task was I I pledge that we
will get there sir I appreciate that all
right okay so um technically
uh this is the this is we don't have we
we generally we don't vote on anything
without an amendment in front of us okay
so what I will say is that we have
scheduled the exact session for what
time
okay so we will um adjourn uh excuse me
we'll what's the right word not adjourn
we uh
recess uh this subcommittee till 3 three
o'clock 3
o'cl today so it'll just be the sub no
say 3:15 is the exact session so that we
can have the subcommittee vote on it
the subcommittee will vote at
3:00 the exec session is at
3:15 we will have an amendment long
before three right
Alex if it doesn't have to go through
legisl it has to go through legislative
services so you just need to you need to
get something for me and I'll get it
over to them and and and we will pull
some strings to make sure legislative
Services gets it done
ASAP but
all
right
okay
e
she
I can assure you I have no desire
whatsoever to be a senator I am
perfectly happy doing what I'm doing
here okay we'll open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 332 and here from
the prime sponsor Senator Ganon good
morning Senator good morning representor
hunt I am Senator Bill Ganon from
District 23 I represent the wine
District as we you call it um so come by
zorinos and I'll buy a drink sometime um
anyways I won't tell you why do I get
everybody Senator wants to buy me a
drink why that's cuz we do all those
fear bills that's another thing um
I'll just cut to the chase really fast
here and let the smart people from the
banking Association follow up so when
you go to apply for a mortgage entities
can purchase the information and that
results in consumers getting bombarded
with hundreds of calls people like me
and older we don't know what's going my
wife gets everything in the mail her
parents get stuff in the mail when
they're applying for loans and so we
want to limit the practice this
legislation will ban that practice it'll
leave an opin provision for the consumer
and they can also it has a carot
provision for communicating with
existing customers I should note that
there is currently a federal bipartisan
legislation that mirrors the proposed
law before you however this practice is
affecting our constituents now there are
several representatives from the bankers
behind me they're going to come with
much more factual information um but
what I'm trying to do is protect
constituents and consumers from the
potential harm by companies who get
their information um and use it to
trigger leads to Mis misrepresent
themselves attempt to confuse or deceive
applicants or inundate them with direct
mailing it has recently come to my
attention also that there's confusion
between the potential for preemption
from the Fair Credit Reporting Act and
also interpretive rule from the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau that
indicates state laws that are not
inconsistent with the
FCC including state laws that are more
protective of consumers than the FC a
general generally not preempted I know
that the house Commerce Committee will
do its due diligence in subcommittee and
give the bill consideration that it
deserves from predatory practices thank
you if there are no questions I'm going
to go to another committee and testify
where I won't read there because it's
more of a subject matter that I'm more
familiar with great thank you very much
great
testimony yeah you just doing the
passing
here good morning ah good morning
chairman Hunton committee members my
name is Steve Bower I'm the executive
director for the Mortgage Bankers and
Brokers Association of New Hampshire
accompanying me is is our uh president-
elect Lisa Ford Lisa has worked in many
capacities in the mortgage real estate
industry for the last two decades she is
here today in her capacity as
the
president-elect and also a homeowner oh
sorry
mbv New Hampshire represents roughly 70
committee members and thousands of
employees consisting a Mortgage Bankers
Credit Services Brokers banks credit
unions appraisal Title Service home
inspectors and other industry related
fields we're here today in support of
Senate Bill 332 limiting predisclosure
of consumer reports with a credit
transaction involving an extension of
credit secured by real estate imagine
walking working into your primary care
physici and they tell you you have high
cholesterol or high blood pressure or
some other ailment and then immediately
sell your medical information the
pharmaceutical companies who bombard you
with phone calls texts emails trying to
sell you medications or rep remedies
Hippa is in place to protect your
medical
privacy the credit
bureau Bureau State that there's an opt
out of pre-screened offer website but it
is not an instant opt out
the time it takes to process the opt out
is one to two weeks and it's too late
people have already gone and they
they've thought they've opt out they go
to the to the mortgage lender and their
that process hasn't happened yet um so
their credit is immediately
sold um so when New Hampshire consistant
apply for a mortgage they have their
credit pulled currently the credit
bureau's TransUnion Equifax Experian
immediately sell that data as a Le
the applicant has bombarded hundreds of
text emails soliciting the in a
predatory manner in many cases these
solicitors are representing themselves
to be working with the applicants chosen
Bank Credit Union or mortgage company
this creates privacy concerns
overwhelming marketing efforts
questionable offers of credit pressure
to make quick decisions and potential
for
scams mvba strongly believes in Fair and
competitive markets but we also believe
safe markets there are many mechanisms
for consumers to opt in to shop for
mortgage and ask for solicit
solicitations by multiple companies with
offers of credit such as bank rate
Lending Tree Zillow there just a few the
bill before us is identical version of
proposed Federal legislation that has
broad bipartisan support in the House
and Senate versions currently over 50
co-sponsors and growing New Hampshire
Senator Jean Shaheen in rep
representative Chris papis are two
co-sponsors and we're hopeful that
Senator Maggie Hassen will will join
soon the bill also provides an optin and
allows for C consumers to choose if they
want to receive offers of credit the
question is are we legally allowed to
pass this bill at the state level
according to the cfpb the super
regulator interpretive rule summary
state laws that are not inconsistent
with Ferra including state laws that are
not more protective of consumers that
the Ferra are generally not
preempted mbba supports protection New
Hampshire constituents and their credit
privacy now soon as possible we know
here in New Hampshire this body is able
to get things
done we ask the committee's support
thank you and now I'll pass it on to
Lisa do you have any direct question we
do representa
Ammon thank you for that testimony uh I
just had a question about the word
certifying in the bill on line
seven um you know maybe maybe you'll
address that in your testimony but how
how does the certification process work
I'm not sure what line seven line seven
I made a couple edits to mine this
morning
certified it says uh documentation to
such agency certifying that such third
part oh I'm sorry you're talking about
the bill I'm sorry
what were you talking about my testimony
oh I'm sorry I don't have that document
yet yeah oh did I give you the
sry get that
to oh so this is the consumer certifying
they they are allowing the the
shared further question may inquire yeah
so so certifying seems to have like an
official connotation to it is are you
saying it's just the consumer some
document where the consumer agreed to
have their information shared excuse me
that is the opt-in provision yes okay
thank you is okay uh represent William
is that on the Hippa form
no I don't I don't I can't answer that
question I don't know he's a mortgage
broker okay yes representative M uh
thank you uh chairman um maybe you don't
know the answer to this question but
periodically I believe a credit card
company that that I have periodically
they look at my credit report now maybe
when I signed up I gave them permission
to do that
is do you know any idea about because th
this I would believe might stop them
from doing that unless somehow I gave
them permission when I signed up for the
credit
card I I will say credit cards are
different than
mortgages okay so they they don't
necessarily all pull from the same they
may only pull from one credit bureau um
and it's not the same uh
permissions okay thank you
representative
P believe me I like the idea but if I
were to deal with a mortgage company
that was not in the state it this bill
would have no effect would it yes it
would because you live in the state if
your mortgage is for the
state if your resid you're applying for
a mortgage for would be within New
Hampshire okay thank
you okay uh I read this bill multiple
times and I'm I'm sure I there's
something I'm
missing if I uh decided to buy property
real estate secured by real estate and
um I am now going to see find I got to
get a mortgage part of my clothing I got
to have a mortgage so I call up my local
bank and I say I want to uh get a Mor Ag
and they're of course they're going to
ask me for my social security number and
they're going to do a credit
check so I haven't talked to anybody I
haven't talked to any credit bureau or
anybody other than that mortgage broker
if you want to call that person at the
bank a mortgage broker I don't know if
they have the number or not but they're
the only ones I have given this
information so you're saying when they
go and click and
onto let's call it Expedia because
that's who I have okay and and I have
I've unlocked that's why I have Expedia
I have it locked so I've unlocked it so
they can get my credit report so there's
a moment in time where it's unlocked and
they're going to get that information
and then theoretically I'll relock it
the next day because they've gotten
their information so where in that
process am I going to be opt in and opt
outing of having information from them
communicated to anybody so thank you
chairman that's a great question I I'm
going to give you a real life example of
myself two weeks ago that applied for a
mortgage okay um for a second home um
when that happened the mortgage company
uses a third party they use they use um
Birchwood services for example that pull
the credit from the three companies
TransUnion Equifax
and Experian um when that happens
somewhere in that time frame there is a
place where you can opt out I didn't
even see it myself when I did this wait
what did you do you all you I applied
for a mortgage did you talk to this
third party company or you talk to your
actual the the lender the lender the
lender and there supposedly there was on
that form there was an opt
out somewhere in that process there is
an opt out out for them to share your
information I don't know where it was I
don't know where it is um within 45
minutes of completing that application
my phone started ringing oh I
nonstop especially a company called
amasap they are Relentless I've blocked
calls I've done all kind they call from
different numbers um some of the
companies when you answer there's nobody
there then they they start talking some
of them pretend to be your lender so
it's very confusing for the consumer and
I'm in the business so I can't even
imagine an elderly person somebody that
you know may have trouble with
understanding the process to begin with
um they get they get railroaded and they
get bombarded and harassed originally it
was created so that people had choice
but this has gone far beyond
choice they they it's harassing
and so that's what this bill is trying
to prevent where they can have a button
to opt in no I got it I got it so um is
it possible that you still have that
form or what you signed into or get
someone else to sign into it and and
then go find where this
opt in in opt out it was available I
mean how do you know how do you know
that they really actually did have that
question how do you know if that opt out
is actually really in
there I I would venture to say is I I I
mean it is true in most of these
documents we get there's a lot of fine
print and a lot of things and but I'm
sure you were very diligent and read all
of
that and made sure that every little
square and especially if you were
supposed to initial that square yeah no
that you would have seen it so I'm I'm
venturing to say is that maybe there not
isn't even that feature available to you
yeah would you believe I haven't applied
for mortgage for a little while but the
only feature I'm aware of is that
there's a online website opt out
pre-screen and you can go there and and
check a box and say you know I want to
opt out of any pre-screened leads um
there's also a phone number that's tied
into with that and I believe that the
credit Bure own that
website um
so if when consumers go there and they
opt out it still it takes one to two
weeks for that process to happen oh I
get that I get the I I'm just wondering
when where this is in the screen and
where is this in the process because I I
would have to say when uh I you know got
a mortgage I don't ever remember having
that screen show up I don't know that
there's ever been
anybody that that isre and and I'll
humor even more because remember I told
I was expedient and I
Expedia monthly Experian excuse me
Experian monthly ask me they say your
credit is so good you probably are
paying too much for auto insurance and
they want to sell me auto
insurance yeah I don't believe there is
a spot on the actual application to opt
out I I don't believe there is I and
some of the people behind can speak to
it um there is no place on the actual
mortgage application it would have to be
an outside
um website that the person would go to
separate from a mortgage right to opt
out and so it's even that is complicated
the reason why I say that is is is it
really the uh the credit bureaus are
doing it or that third-party company who
who is supposed to be doing that
background I'm betting they're the ones
who are selling it
yes so the problem is UN possibility for
us because if we're making legislation
about credit bureaus how do we control
these out
ofate
uh companies that are are are
actually not doing what they're should
be doing which is Le giving you the
opportunity to upt in or upt out they're
not even giving that because you don't
you know how you most of us probably
have no idea that there was a third-
party inventor involved even when we
talk to our mortgage broker even talk to
the bank they're probably not going to
mention that it was a third party
it they
get beat up or complained against from
their customer that hey how am I why am
I getting all these leads um all these
messages and text messages and things
like that so they think it's the local
person that's caused that right and it's
not it's the Transunion eifax and
experience it's not them
no it's at that Source these third
parties have contracts with them to buy
pre-screen leads so they they they'll
put together a a you know I want a 700
score I want somebody that's you know
buying a $500,000 house and when these
Hits come in from the credit pull that
our local virtu with credit services
doing they have to come from from the
three okay and that's what causes that's
where the the lead is sold to these
bureaus okay and and I also take this
opportunity to let everybody know
because this is a previous legislation
that after you've recorded that
mortgage that is now public information
and that there's these Mor these uh
insurance companies who want to sell you
mortgage insurance go down to to the
clerk's office and collects all those
recorded mortgages and sends you a
mailer and don't you know on the top of
that mailer is the name of your
financial institution that you got your
mortgage with so watch out for those yes
represented
Texon well just so I'm
clear there's there's actually there's
three there's your lend your there's
your originating lender which might be a
mortgage broker or a bank or a credit
union and they've called for
consolidated credit report and score
from a third-party company that then
goes and contacts the three major credit
bureaus uh TransUnion Equifax and
experion or Expedia if you like to
travel
uh and
the goal of this bill is to
stop which of those so it's not your
originating it's not your originating
lender and it's not the third party
company it's actually what you're saying
if I understand you correctly what
you're saying is it's the Bure it's the
three credit bureaus they're selling
this lead is that what and the goal of
this bill is contention is that it's the
credit bureau yes it is the three credit
bureaus that are selling these pre which
you might not have any relationship with
at all you've never even gone on to
their web page you but they have a
relationship with you because your all
of your creditors your credit card your
car payment whatever certainly know a
lot about they've reported
all yeah they've I did one the other day
and they wanted they asked me about an
address that I had in 1979 and it's like
what um
so and your it's your feeling that this
bill would stop the the three credit
bureaus from selling that lead that's my
question it's what we're trying to do is
give them some more clear uh guard rails
the first is to offer the consumer the
right to opt in because currently
they're already opted in just by being a
consumer so they don't have a say unless
they go to the opt out prescreen website
and click there I want to opt out which
again is a delayed process
so even if that could be changed so that
the opt out is immediate it should be as
fast to opt out as it is for them to
sell the
leads well I agree with that you know
the Savings Bank of Walpole has I I can
opt out of them selling my information
they're very care and they very
carefully once a year send me a notice
and says this is what we do with your
information internally do we sell and my
credit card companies do and all that
but my my feeling is it and I believe me
I'm not here saying oh I think I love
credit bureaus I think that's great no I
think they should be constrainted but if
we agree to this bill my question is is
it is it going to actually do the job is
it going to stop the it's the credit
bureaus that are selling these leads to
other lenders and this bill is going to
put the brakes on them it should slow
them down and the third thing that it's
that it's designed to do is that it
restricts
the the pre-screen leads that they can
sell which are to somebody that has a
business relationship with them with a
mortgage um you know there's three
reasons in there
why but some but the customer they have
to have a a relationship with whoever
they're selling that lead to outside of
that somebody without a relationship it
stops
that so it would stop the bill this bill
would stop it from I go and get a
mortgage from the Savings Bank of
Walpole I have a relationship with them
and then it stops Equifax from selling
that lead to Wells Fargo for a car loan
represent thank you Mr chair I just had
one further question the the
organization that you represent um
you're taking a position as an
organization on this legislation I just
I'm curious how does it affect your
business and your membership of your
organization uh you know obviously
there's some negative effect that your
membership has because of what's
Happening status quo so if you could
explain that please
well the negative effect of all the
complaints that come back to them
because their customers getting swamped
with all these leads and they can't
figure out where they're coming from so
as an association when we talked about
this bill we had
100% support because everybody wants
this cleaned up and it's a na it's a
nationwide issue it's it's that's why
there's so much support in DC it's just
nothing happens in DC so you have to
take it at a state level and that's sort
today I would say as an organization it
doesn't affect us directly but it
affects our members and so we're here in
support of our
members representative M uh thank you um
so you recently filled out a mortgage
application wouldn't it make sense if
that opt in opt out was on the mortgage
application so when your bank goes to to
this third party right up front it says
you can't sell this or give this
information and if and again you said
you didn't see that on your mortgage
application but could something be put
in the law here that it that opt in opt
out has to be on the mortgage
application well that would be a cfpb
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
which you know oversees that um but that
would make sense I don't know that that
could be affected in the in the state
it's their form y all right it's a
federal form there's some other speakers
behind us that can speak to that bill
that
question representative txon I I
apologize I walked in late who do you
represent what is your
organization The Mortgage Bankers and
Brokers Association of New
Hampshire so it's lenders and then all
it oh and Banks and credit unions it's
the whole all the stock all because
they're getting tired of having the
customers call and say why am I getting
all this junk mail thanks for sending me
all this junk mail thank you very much
thank you thank you okay so let's hear
that's uh I would say that my loan is a
jumbo loan and no it's not even on the
good morning good morning thank you for
having me I'm Zachary Taylor I'm the
director of government relations for the
consumer data industry Association we
represent uh Experian Equifax TransUnion
uh other credit bureaus especially
credit bureaus and other companies
involved in identity verification fraud
detection Etc we do not represent
Expedia I would like to put that on the
record
for um as as you might imagine we are
opposed to to Senate Bill 332 um we view
it as anti-competitive and
anti-consumer uh it restricts the
ability of consumers to hear alternative
offers um from other Mortgage Bankers
and brokers who are subscribers to
mortgage trigger Services which are
regulated by the Fair Credit Reporting
Act um there's already a robust consumer
opt out provision you've heard some
misinformation this morning about the
time in which that is processed nothing
this bill would require anyone who is
offering
or working with a consumer on a mortgage
to actually present them with the opt
out or the opt in and so what we're
seeing and what I would point out is
that this bill really is going to harm
the ability of New Hampshire consumers
to potentially hear the best possible
offers out there and an environment
where interest rates are so incredibly
High a better offer means saving tens of
thousands of dollars over the life of a
30-year mortgage um the FC has been
around since 1976 consumers have the
opportunity to call 885 opt out if they
want to stop phone solicitations that's
managed by the Federal Trade Commission
or they can visit optoutprescreen.com
which will stop mail solicitations
either permanently or for five years and
that includes for credit card offers as
well prescreened offers of credit are
regulated by the FC they're also
preempted by the FC we've heard a little
bit of conversation about the cfpb uh
what we call the advisory opinion we
think the cfpb was wrong on the process
they issued that without putting it
through the APA procedure required by
federal agencies in DC they issued it
also it's wrong on the law we've seen
court cases across the country that have
upheld the broad preemptive authority of
the Fair Credit Reporting Act as it
relates to prescreened offers of credit
um and I'm happy to go into that further
in Greater detail um but most
importantly in the cfpb opinion they're
discussing other provisions of law from
across the country regarding the
information contained in a consumer
report uh not
necessarily prescreened offers of credit
which are expressly preempted by the FC
and I have that with me I'm happy to
walk through that as well um all in all
we think that this is a a bad Bill we
think this is a bill that is going to
make it difficult for consumers to hear
the best offer it doesn't require any
lender Bank to actually disclose the
opt-in procedures if it wasn't preempted
um and so consider that um but happy to
take any questions I did want to answer
a few things that I heard uh from
previous questions um notably uh how
this process works so the FC requires
that when you apply for a credit card
when you apply for a loan when you apply
for a mortgage that application shows up
for a period of one year on your credit
report that information as well as your
name and phone number may be given to a
third party that does not have an
existing relationship with the consumer
this is a pre-screened offer of credit
um again consumers have the ability to
opt out from this if they do not want to
receive these but that would also stop
the offers to get credit cards in the
mail for the latest travel card or other
products that you may be interested in
or offers to save money on your
insurance it would be
blanket um I'd also point out that we're
required to have that information on
there Federal Law requires us to include
those records as well as other things uh
so we would be in a situation where New
Hampshire state law is saying we may not
share information that a federal law
says we may share if the consumer has
not opted out um and I'm happy to to go
just chapter and verse here very quick
um just for everyone to hear so General
exceptions no requirement or prohibition
may be imposed under the laws of any
state with respect to any subject matter
regulated under a subsection C or E of
section 604 of this title relating to
the prescreening of consumer reports
that is the first section of what is
preempted by the FC from States
regulating what is being discussed here
today are pre-screened reports and thus
We Believe 332 would be preempted as
other courts across the country have
found happy to answer any further
questions about the cfp uh
preemption and and how that would
work
okay I guess I would have to
say personally that when
I let's go let's go to those classic
frequent fire Myers like JetBlue wanted
me to right on the airplane right
they're saying if you you know sign up
for this JetBlue credit card right now
will give you 50,000 or 75,000 points
right you know good for no trip so what
I'm just heard is is that if I were
foolishly enough to fill that out and I
can guarantee you there's nothing in
there that's going to tell me about opt
out or opt in okay there's nothing in
there um what I like in this to be is
more like um don't you know that uh you
can uh call up there's a an email
address called do not call MH and so but
I have to remember that that fires every
eight years so I have to go back on
every eight years and put my all my
phone numbers back in again to get rid
of the Do Not calls all right so what
I'm saying is is that what we have here
is an in there is an entity to stop all
this junk mail to stop all this stuff
you just have to know about it so I
would urge the mortgage brokers to make
sure when your customer is signing up
that you do give them a little piece of
paper with that phone number or email
address to say immediately and when they
do it
because I foolishly thought there was a
right of privacy here I I really did not
think that my application where I
foolishly write my annual income and I
will say with the mic on I don't give
that know IRS gets good numbers all
right that that having said that that
that form is sitting around hanging
around for a year and and and then who
knows can go go look at it and then send
me you know more Airline flight frequent
fire Mouse Okay so it is a little
bothersome to know that the system is
such that getting credit that I when I
when I go to my Experian and turn it off
and give a credit report to somebody
that all of a sudden that is now being
public information all over so yes I I
would say is I I don't envy you in your
job
but at the end of the day the federal
government should resolve this problem
because this is not right okay this is
really not right if I if I may chair I I
just want to provide a little bit of
clarification about what is shared in a
pre-screened mortgage trigger okay
limits on the information received under
paragraph 1B the name and address of a
consumer and identifier that is not
unique to the consumer that used by the
person solely for the purpose of
verifying the identity of the consumer
other information pertaining to a
consumer that does not identify the
relationship or experience of the
consumer with respect to a particular
creditor or entity so federal law also
prohibits us from sharing a pre-existing
relationship with a creditor to another
creditor except our mailing address yes
it does allow the share of the address
right so then they can do their
profiling based upon my mailing address
okay all right I think I got it now
thank you and the other question
represent
Solan um well first of all I like your
um they're good luck it's like
a
like anyways um so I mean I you know I
always I always sort of kind of roll my
eyes a little bit when people say you're
looking out for my best interest by
selling my data and making money off of
my data I mean that's just I mean it's I
don't think that Rings particularly
sincere to probably the majority of
people in this room because all of of us
are annoyed by the junk mail we get all
of us are annoyed by the text messages
and phone calls we get and all of us are
annoyed by the emails being sold I mean
I have an
entirely my email account from that I my
very first one I ever created back in
high school is now just my soul junk
anything I sign up for I have to sign up
with that because it is such a problem
right everything is sold and at the end
of the day like yes there might be
people who are benefiting from the
ability to see a bunch of offers sent to
them when you're over welmed with a lot
of offers it's really hard to Screen
through those I mean that in itself
takes a separate set of skills when you
are I mean there was a time a while back
where I was looking to refinance a home
and I mean I had what was described by
the previous speaker where I mean within
seconds of filling something out I had
so many phone calls I was like I can't
keep up with this like this is like this
is overwhelming me and I'm not at that
time I was probably like 30 I I I'm not
somebody in my 70s who could beat easily
overwhelmed right so you know I don't
understand why we need to have a opt in
opt out instead of an opt
in so thank you for the the question
represent I think Point points certainly
understood I think this is the challenge
where we run into the state law would
conflict with the federal law the
federal law says that these products are
legal and lawful under the FC that they
can uh be offered and that many mortgage
bankers and Brokers rely on them to find
leads um I think we are in an
environment because of high interest
rates that there is a smaller pool and
that we have seen historically that as
those rates rise and fall this issue
pops up to the Forefront time and again
um but the FC does allow for us to share
a consumer report relating
to uh these these um transactions if
it's not initiated by the consumer if
the transaction consists of a firm offer
of credit or insurance and the consumer
reporting agency is complying with SE
section e um which means which deals
with the opt out sections and so for
right now federal law says there is an
opt out procedure and it must be
respected other states who have looked
at this issue have looked at the
requirements imposed on users of these
Services uh other states like
Massachusetts have codified uh
violations of those requirements is
unfair deceptive trade practices so
again this is not we're is not Experian
or Equifax or TransUnion making the
phone calls to Consumers it's mortgage
brokers and it's Bankers who are
subscribed to these Services competing
over the same number of mortgages that
are being written or not written and
they are the ones making the call
there's you know laws that require clear
disclosure um that uh the person calling
identify that they are not with the
originating lender um as far as mail
prescreened that you get the junk mail
the credit card offers or mortgage
offers you get in the mail um If you're
receiving written solicitations they
must be accompanied with a notice that
the consumer has the right to opt out
from such solicitations the FC requires
this notice to be in a manner that is
simple and easy to understand the FDC
has determined that to meet the
statutory criteria the notice of the
right opt out must be in two places and
must be clear and so right now FC and
the FCC have looked at this and said
there has to be an opt out there is an
opt out in statute and so that is what
is available to Consumers and the FC
also says that state laws that attempt
to create additional restrictions on the
use of these products would be preempted
and the cfpb opinion does get into that
as it talks about specific sections of
Statute that are specifically referenced
in the preemption section uh and the
subject matter regulated thereunder and
subsection C uh is Furnishing reports in
connection with credit or Insurance
transactions that are not initiated by
the consumer and so that is
preempted follow
up
so I mean I ended up with a question
question um so is your is a position of
you and your agency that you're
concerned about the conflict between
state and federal law or is the position
that we should actually have opt opt out
as the default or op versus opt in like
like if if the feds change it would you
guys be fighting against an opt in
change so consumer reporting agencies
are repositories of information
regarding credit transactions and other
identifying information that is used to
verify and price right and so we are
like the library people give us
information we hold to it furnishers
like Banks provide us that information
um and so we are not actually engaging
directly with the consumer in most
instances the information is provided to
us the government the covenants
regarding the Furnishing that
information are heavily regulated the FC
heavily regulates what and how it can be
furnished um nothing in this bill would
require a mortgage Banker broker to
either inform a consumer that they have
the right to opt out or require them to
opt into sharing and talking with our
member companies they say it takes
between 24 to 48 hours to process an opt
out notice um and again it's if you opt
out through the website that's for mail
you have to call the FTC to opt out via
phone and so we get the information
about an application for mortgage from a
mortgage Banker or mortgage broker that
is compiled that information submitted
to us at that point we have to put it on
the consumer's credit file to comply
with federal law at that point other
subscribers to mortgage trigger services
are legally allowed to be notified that
is a consumer that fits profile X that
has applied for a transaction and that
is what triggers uh that disclosure and
in some cases it may get a better deal
in some cases they may get 75 phone
calls but one more
try give it up he's just repeating
himself he's going to keep reading the
same thing over and over and hope that
you're going to I was hoping to get just
an answer the position would be like if
they if the feds tried to change and
make it opt in instead of opt out you
guys would oppose that so the federal
the changes if you can't answer that
just stop he's not going to answer that
question he's not gonna answer that
question he's
not okay representative
spear he said that there was a uh do not
call thing that you can call up with the
government I did that month after month
after month and it never stopped
anything it never had any effect so what
exactly is that do
well the FTC has to enforce it and if
their calls are coming from outside the
country I don't know where the ftc's
regulatory reach ends but if there are
us-based Mortgage Bankers or mortgage
brokers calling you in violation of the
FTC and do our call list then uh under
some state laws that comply with the FC
that would be an unfair and deceptive
trade practice that various enforcement
mechanisms may be available to Consumers
there I would say the best way the best
trick I had in dealing with that um a
you can get rid of your land landline
because it's landline okay but B is what
I had right next to my phone is I had a
a a piece of paper and they would start
out saying the organization and I said
um I would confirm it so you said this
is the or get I get them to confirm the
organization great so I want you to know
that um I'm writing down this call that
I'm about to tell you to do not call and
if you call again I will ensure that I
can now tell the FTC exactly when you
call called what time you called and
that I told you to put me on the Do Not
Call List and I'll tell you it has been
successful I got to tell you what I
did the problem you have I have to tell
you what I did when when I got those
phone calls I said you are calling into
a secure facility in Area
51 if you don't get off the phone no no
your phone is going to be traced and
that's the only thing and getting rid of
the landline was the only thing that
stopped it the with these lists that
they have is that you get on these do
not call lists and some company in M
Mumbai India gets that list and then
they call that list they call that list
yeah that's find the ones that are
overseas I do get a boop boop you know
they get a little I get a little sound
and I know to crank hang it up before
they thank you very much thank you chair
thank you okay we do have a couple more
cards here and senator's back okay so uh
I good morning good morning so me still
morning yeah thank you Mr chairman um
and and thank you on behalf of everyone
in the room we're going to get all sorts
of Facebook advertisement now for
Expedia so I'm curious to see what
vacations they're going to be offering
me uh my name is Ray Tweety and I live
in the town of Ry New Hampshire I'm a
producing branch manager with a
Waterstone mortgages Portsmouth office
out on the former peas Air Force Base
I've been in the banking business for
almost 30 years um Senate Bill 332
before you was designed to protect
consumers who in very simple terms have
had their credit pulled in relation to a
transaction involving real estate
at present when a hard credit poll is
done a person's information is sold in
many different ways by the credit
reporting repositories as a lead even
though the lender is paid for that
credit beerer in the first place and the
hard poll was authorized by them the by
the consumer to them from this point I
call it literally Off to the Races as
you've heard with a previous speaker
before me with the amount of calls and
emails and text messages that they will
get from other lenders who have
purchased their information um I offer
you the following real life life example
uh one of my colleagues had a call with
a borrower on the 7th of April a Sunday
for a loan request uh he was lucky
enough to put a home under agre which is
extremely hard to do not only in New
Hampshire but really across the country
due to lack of inventory the application
and the credit poll were done Sunday the
7th in the early afternoon by Wednesday
the loan officer checked in with the
client to let him know the loan was
moving through to processing Wednesday
the 10th the client reported back to the
loan officer there were literally 200
phone calls to his cell phone his
voicemail box was filled up twice
because he kept deleting the messages
and then gave up so aside from being
what I would consider overly aggressive
on the part of the lead callers the
client had no ability for anyone in his
family or otherwise to leave a message
because of these calls many of these
telemarketers I call them are licensed
but they are very koi in what they say I
will not go so far as to say that they
are breaking the law but in my
professional opinion they are less than
forthcoming and unethical in the way
they speak with people their statements
mislead some who do not do this stuff
this sort of thing every day and they
may not pay attention verbatim to what
they say I've had my own clients
mistakingly think they are helping a
member of my processing team and have
accidentally applied for credit
elsewhere this becomes a problem in some
cases for the clients because multiple
credit scores can reduce their score and
if their scores on the edge of a
particular program or rate tier that
could offer them a discount they may
lose it they may lose an approval all
together in one case a client of mine
unknowingly applied with the existing
servicer who also originates and because
of that application we lost her
appraisal waiver which is a a waiver we
get through an automated system that
says you don't need an appraisal because
we accept your value uh we lost her
appraisal waiver this delayed her
closing and it added the cost of an
appraisal because we had to rush an
appraisal to meet a closing deadline
because we lost it due to this confusion
on her part so that was as a result of
the other lenders action she thought she
was helping us out um I understand that
there's pending Federal legislation we
talked about that earlier in Washington
regarding this topic um and there may be
a thought for some of you to wait on the
feds to solve this problem but I urge
you not to and I don't need to share
with any of you in this room that
Washington is broken I don't care on
what side of the aisle you sit um and it
could really take a lesson on how things
happen from all of you here in New
Hampshire I think we do it well and we
do it better um I think the speaker down
there wakes up every day wondering if he
has a job and he's trying to read tea
leaves um I don't envy him um none of
that nonsense helps get a bill passed
and it leaves us without being able to
protect consumers um which is what we're
trying to do here so um I have before
you a copy of the ficra ruling and I'd
be happy to entertain any questions
because I actually do this every day so
me great thank you I think we're all
questioned out all right wonderful well
thank you for having me all right thank
D good morning Mr chairman chairman hunt
and the members of the committee uh my
name is Charlie D and I work for the New
Hampshire Mutual Bank Corp which is
Meredith Village Savings Bank savings
Bank of walpool and marac County Savings
Bank uh as many of you aware when you
buy a house it's the biggest purchase of
your lifetime generally it's it's a
really big deal for it's a it's a filled
with anxiety and stress uh and as a
community bank we do a lot of them and
we have a trust relationship with the as
the custodians of our clients money so
they trust
us so when they apply for Real Estate
loan they often do it at night or early
in the morning when they when they're
not at work
so they can focus and get everything
together uh they provide all of their
information so after they submit it and
agree to have their credit pulled
because you can't really figure out if
you're credit worthy without having your
credit pulled the phone starts ringing
starts ringing
Non-Stop and for people who have English
as a second language or people who are
elderly they pick the phone up and they
just assume it's the bank calling
because they just applied they're like
wow these guys are good they call me
right
away
so I don't know if it's intentional or
unintentional but the people that are
calling are really playing off on that
um and that that's a problem especially
for people want to do a reverse
mortgage they're doing reverse mortgage
because they run out of money they got
to figure out how to get some money out
of their house so they can continue to
survive
um we we have to figure out a
way to stop this right we can agree that
this legislation federally and what have
you but it's not working so as state
legislators we have the opportunity to
take a look at this problem and figure
out a way to solve it the way that we do
things in New Hampshire for our people
um the fear and anxiety that comes up on
these people when they start getting
2030 calls and then they can't even
figure out who they're supposed to call
sometimes they haven't spoken to the
loan officer yet they talked to the
person at you know at the bank their
banker and they said just go online and
apply and then they'll call it so it's
it's a it's a relatively large problem
and it's it's impacting our
questions I guess we're all said thank
you we have no more cards so we'll close
start represent I wish You' been in the
I thought I was going to do my last bill
in front of you it was
um uh whether ra should be counted as
employees or not I thought that would
have come to you it was so it it
colleges right now in Ira is not
considered anlo
and they want to treat them as employees
well so they can tax them yeah know I
thought you'd get it so I was like I
didn't have anything I did a half hour
of talking I hate coming in reading
things bothers
anything well I had an immigration Bill
two weeks ago that I thought I did well
on I had nothing I just had nothing we
just talked for an hour then I did one
for driver's licenses yesterday I was
not happy I had a written thing and I
stuck to the script it was I never like
yes
yeah yeah I do like 12 of my own and
then I got like 12 Department bills the
own ones I do much better when I'm doing
my
good morning Senator ganet thank you
representative hunt always good to see
you um again uh the folks at the New
Hampshire Tech Alliance came to me and
they said um about sponsoring a piece of
legislation I said no I got too many
bills right um but they said no we'll do
the heavy work and I said well what's it
about and they said we're losing funds
in New Hampshire we have startup Tech
businesses but we don't get any direct
support so they said we're losing
opportunities we're watching them go to
other states and we would like
to have a commission and the ideas to
get people to work with um diverse
startup companies to get a better
understanding of the opportunities and
they identify the steps so I have very
knowledgeable people behind me who are
going
to go further into it than that but
that's I have to say thank you thank you
very much you guys have a great day yep
Scott good
morning good morning morning Mr chair me
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Scott Merrick uh I'm a
former member from the North Country
having served from 04 to 09 and it's
great to be back here in a slightly
different capacity on the other side of
the tables I'm here today in my capacity
as a board member of the New Hampshire
Tech Alliance and chair of their
government Affairs committee typically
Julie demur the executive director of
the New Hampshire Tech Alliance would be
sitting here but she's out of town and I
am pinch hitting on her behalf I
appreciate appreciate the opportunity to
briefly address the committee in support
of SP
477 for those of you who are not
familiar with the New Hampshire Tech
Alliance it is a Statewide bi technology
Association that represents nearly 250
technology companies ranging from
startups to Enterprise technology
companies these 250 member companies
collectively employ close to 50,000 Tech
workers in the state annually we
facilitate 30 programs aimed at
fostering growth within the dynamic
landscape of New Hampshire's tech
industry New Hampshire has a lot of
advantages to offer startup businesses
Workforce quality of life access access
to decision makers however there have
been multiple National reports that rank
New Hampshire incredibly low in
comparison to other states as a place to
grow and Enterprise according to CNBC
wallet Hub US News and World Report New
Hampshire ranked 35th 34th and 39th out
of 50 states respectfully indicators
such as Venture Capital Investments
state-backed Capital loan guarantees
Health Science and agricultural research
Grant Awards numbers of patents issued
per capita are all indicators in which
New Hampshire scores poorly across a
variety of reports we can simply
speculate why this is the case but a
study commission will allow us to
comprehensively map existing resources
for ENT entrepreneurs in our state it
will identify areas for improvement and
promot promote cross- sector initiatives
that strengthen our entrepreneurial
ecosystem and consequently the overall
economy building robust Innovative
innovation ecosystems requires
collaboration from all stakeholders
public private and Academia it depends
on long-term Vision that transcends
political cycles and partis and agendas
establishing a study commission is the
pivotal first step toward creating a
shared Vision it provides the technology
sector and our legislators the
opportunity to collaboratively work
towards Solutions tailored to our state
on behalf of the New Hampshire Tech
Alliance board of directors membership
and Technology sector as a whole I ask
for your support in moving this critical
legislation forward happy to take any
questions thank
spe okay if you've ever uh participated
or have seen some of our study
commissions there are a few that have
been successful most have not it seems
to me that the kind of information that
you
want you folks and your Association are
in a best position to tell us what needs
to be done rather than us trying to who
have don't have the group experience
that you have so it seems to me a better
approach might be for you to tell us
what you need and then us for us to work
on it rather than go the other way
around so my suggestion would be try
that approach instead uh representative
gosh I would hate to just come in here
and tell you exactly what to do and walk
out of the building
uh but certainly yeah know I I
appreciate the comment you know I think
our the the alliance uh looks at this as
an
opportunity uh you know I'd say two or
three-fold first to work collaboratively
with legislators to educate to
understand the issue Better B to work
together to look at Best Practices
across States and see what New Hampshire
could do that is uniquely New Hampshire
and have buyin from the beginning rather
than come in here and just tell you what
we think is best and then go through a
process which is questioning why are you
doing this why are you doing that where
we have answered all of that in
collaboration with all of you so we
think this is an opportunity to work
together uh and hopefully in in a
relatively efficient and effective
process uh over the coming you know six
to eight months come up with
recommendations uh and move forward with
the state collaboratively I have a
question representative Ammon is
next thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony um I'm just out of
curiosity uh I have two related
questions um what what industries do you
think New Hampshire could uh capture
what growth industries are there that
New Hampshire could capture and secondly
what impediments do you see uh that the
state government could help with uh in
overcoming yeah good questions and I
don't want to necessarily speak out of
turn because while I chair the
government Affairs committee s the board
I think there are a lot of different
sectors that could benefit that I uh can
only kind of speak anally to I may ask
Taylor Grande who works on our startup
initiative to also speak to this because
I think uh she has a bit more knowledge
into the specific sectors but just kind
of off the top of Mind in terms of where
we can benefit I think biomedtech is one
of those places uh certainly AI as we
are struggling and trying to figure out
how AI uh is going to work across the
board uh and how that you know impacts
our startup Community uh certainly I
think there's opportunity there uh but I
think just broadly when we're looking at
kind of the startup Community as an
ecosystem as a whole you know it doesn't
really necessarily depend on which
sector we are are lacking in New
Hampshire across the board in terms of
kind of a state supported ecosystem and
then you talk about where could these
State be helpful um I don't want to
necessarily assume uh because I think
there could be a lot of opportunities
Taylor worked uh in other states helping
them to build their ecosystem so I would
ask actually Taylor to to flag exactly
where some of those places were if if
it's all right with the chair to have
Taylor come up and quickly address the
question of course I have a question
when she sits down
okay good morning I'm gonna huddle over
here I'm about six months pregnant so
give me some time to Waddle uh good
morning everyone um like I Scott said
I'm Taylor Grande I just moved to New
Hampshire from Colorado where I was the
CEO of um a uh multi-million dollar uh
Statewide nonprofit organization called
startup Colorado that was originally
founded um under the startup America
initiative uh and was founded by our
state attorney general Phil Weiser and a
gentleman named Brad Feld who was the
co-founder of tech stars um which is an
accelerator program uh to help early
stage Tech startups across the world so
good to see everyone today and I can
help answer any questions that I have
but I am fairly new to the
state ask your
question yeah if I could just repeat the
same question um I think we heard Ai and
biotech um just what industries could we
Foster so we can get ahead of the curve
and uh how did Colorado assist as a
state government I mean it's a
completely different state so let's just
it's a elephant in the room there the
tax you know the tax system is different
the the size of the state government is
is quite different um the types of
companies that are coming out of
Colorado are quite different than we're
seeing here in New Hampshire but uh it
was across the board in terms of
Industry I think Scott you're you're
right in saying that to make assumptions
around a specific area sector industry
um when you take a look at at Colorado
we had such success because we were open
to all Industries we had a we had a lot
of advanced manufacturing we had outdoor
recreation um as early stage companies
you know Tech is Tech most people think
of tech because you think of of Shark
Tank right it's it's Chang the way that
we think about investing uh in early
stage companies from a VC landscape um
but so manyan outside of tech um are are
receiving outside Capital um you know to
help them scale at an early stage and
and along every every stage of their
company's life cycle so I would need to
take a look at um you know at what
industries have seen success here um but
Colorado there's a lot of good models to
take a look at from Colorado um you know
that I'd be happy to to talk through and
in other states as well I think the
thing that I'm most excited about coming
here as a as a new number is that um you
know study commissions can uh can can be
a waste of time but they can also be
really really pivotal in terms of
collaboration with state government
because you're walking hand inand taking
a look at what the big problems are and
how to assess those from a startup
ecosystem development landscape and and
we did that um in Colorado we had you
know the the board of the uh the Bea
here it's equivalent it's their office
of Economic Development and
international trade for Colorado um that
that person who spaned it across uh
multiple
administrations sat on our board uh of
Directors
for nine years um and really was a
pivotal partner for
us and real quickly uh represent amayan
just to kind of continue answering your
question um opportunities for where the
state could be really helpful uh working
with the private sectors first of all I
I think um what Senator Gan mentioned in
terms of a lot of money being left on
the table I think a lot of VC's and
early stage investors look for uh a
supportive ecosystem before they look to
invest in startup communities and
startup companies um and I think just a
a general hey we are supportive we're
working and vote with the private sector
to help support the startup community be
that you know whether it's uh
financially or otherwise certainly I
think there are a lot of opportunities
for the state to kind of extand that
that hand and really say that hey we're
open for for business but specifically
we're going to work with the startup
community and do what we can to help
Foster a really diverse and dynamic
ecosystem okay uh Nas
next thanks for taking my question this
is a would you believe um if there is a
commission I think that it will be
really important to figure out where
you're going to house workers because we
can't house the people that we have now
that's a huge problem in Colorado as
well okay it's tough um it's a national
Problem Child Care is the same way it's
the reason that we left Colorado in you
know so Workforce is obviously a huge uh
retracted for folks who are starting
businesses here but because there is
such a strong landscape um you know in
terms of the tax burden for for
employees that's a great way to to
attract the workforce here but they're
they're up against so many other issues
Workforce childcare as you mentioned um
you know I met with a I was just meeting
with a an investor yesterday morning and
he said you know I wouldn't start a
business anywhere else except New
Hampshire but I'm but I'm puzzled why
there aren't more companies that are
starting in New Hampshire because
there's nowhere to live there's nowhere
to live right that's but but it's
multifaceted you know when you when you
take a look at the resources that are
available from a Statewide
landscape it's there's there's certainly
gaps um when you talk about the early
stage if you look at if you look at an
ecosystem of companies as a pipeline and
you are expecting we're all wanting more
second stage scalable companies to exist
to start and scale and remain here in in
New Hampshire you can't get to that
second stage Point unless you're tending
to the top of the funnel across all
Industries and sectors and and providing
resources at every level or every stage
of a company's life cycle so yes child
you know childcare and Healthcare huge
issues but I think what we're experts in
is really providing the business support
and being laser focused in that and
partnering with those folks on on the
economic development lens you know to to
solve these multitude of
problems question I wish you good luck I
really do and I don't mean that I don't
mean that in a snarky way I really don't
repres
bam thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Scott this one is for
you um does the state have a um
Innovative fund um sort of a grant
process the state sets aside some money
for innovators in the state do you know
anything about not that I believe so no
not right now and and and that's you
know certainly when I when I was in my
original testimony uh had FL you know
certain Awards Grant Awards and
opportunities uh for the state to
partner um and and I don't believe that
we do have anything like that but I also
think you know it's not just the state
funding but also you know there could be
Federal opportunities that flow through
the state right um that we should be
looking out for as well but again those
are all things that I think the
commission would look at to see how can
New Hampshire and its own way uh
identify opportunities be it's state
federal or otherwise uh to help support
and promote yeah there was a fund years
uh years ago because I remember going to
some you know uh
exhibits um so if that's no longer
available from the state then yeah and
and I know there are uh and I'm not
overstating here there are literally
millions of dollars kind of just sitting
on the table um if and when there's a
fund available uh for matching funds
yeah there was the mil Works fund as you
might may remember Mill Works fund one
and two that received some um some
capital and investment from the BFA um a
while back but that's not active in
terms of capital investment right now so
I I have a little bit to offer here um
on my on my other life I sit on a family
foundation and uh and I'm on the energy
committee and the state of Ohio put up a
million dollars to create the bright
innovators and the bright in five C3 and
they and they they put in feed startup
monies a couple hundred, here couple
100,000 there and and get these
Innovative and and it's all focused on
energy now I say that only because um
you guys don't give yourself a lot of
time to get anything done here this bill
your your effective date you know
passage which as we know that's the end
you know sometime in June but you're
supposed to you're all done by November
1st did you mean to do that we in the
small business sector like to be
efficient as effective as possible with
our time and yours but if you believe
certainly chairman in your wisdom uh and
experience in doing this that that date
should be extended we are uh happy to
entertain an amendment to do so uh we
hope that we can bring together the
right group of people and get this work
done quickly uh to make recommendations
for the next legisl session but again uh
Mr chair I I would well given you know
you got all these different appointees
and my experience is that you're lucky
to get them all appointed by the end of
August so yes you have to be a model of
efficiency you're going to three months
to get it done so uh we might want to
look at that ABS but U having said that
that reason why model legislation has
that date in there is that they keep
telling us they don't want these
commissions and they they're so which
begs the question
is uh why isn't who was the tech you
were why isn't the tech Alliance why
aren why aren't you guys laying the
ground work to create this nonpr create
a nonprofit that people can give money
they they're all begging they all got
that money out there they just need an
entity to give it to and get that going
and maybe you know you know mean I
understand we can get you this
commission but the amount of or your
organization to get the meetings OCC to
get them on time and before you know it
your your clocks run out on you so I
just hope you have all that in mind two
two thoughts certainly Happ been happy
to consider extending the day of the
commission um but there is no really
nowhere for that money to go because
it's not just that the money's there
it's that they're looking for a partner
in the state right you got to create the
nonprofit well it's not even a nonprofit
they're looking for the state government
to be involved and To Be A Champion to
be part of this process help you're
looking for us to put money in not
necessarily and I think that's the
purpose of this commission is that like
yes is that an opportunity absolutely
but there are other ways for the state
to also be a partner in the startup
ecosystem be it financially or otherwise
so I think there are I guess I guess
what I'm saying is rethink that because
Ohio did it a different way and there's
a successful and it's operating and it's
actually working so they if you're if
you're depending upon the state to
create an entity an agency or something
to have some ownership that you're
you're going to be wasting your time you
know because we we don't do that you as
you probably
know I know we are careful with our
money for sure
okay okay representative Herbert you can
have your question okay thanks um thank
you that was what you just discussed was
my first thought and that is where
where's the money going to come from now
I don't know if I don't have any idea as
to whether the states other states have
got a conduit uh for federal funds and
and if and if they do what did they do
in order
to uh access that money because this
state is to say it's Frugal is a gross
underst understanding that's a good
thing yeah so um but that was the second
my second thought is that there's a lot
of money in this state and there are
there are
investors private equity investors
billionaires
who have houses here and live here and
and and to have a state agency be
created with a that kind of um focus
probably would be relatively inexpensive
but uh pretty effective so I've got two
questions there number one how are we
going to get how are we getting fall uh
failing to get Federal funding through
our Congressional Delegation or whatever
purpose and two uh as a I think it is a
good idea although the chair is
skeptical that the state would have fund
a uh has to be two or three people you
know this is not a big deal in this
state you have can go out and and gain
capital and of course there's it's a
two-way street so if somebody comes
along and says
yeah uh I think I'd like to you know I
can spend you know like $50 million we
don't want you to do that so thank you
you don't want me to do what keep going
you ask your question I okay my question
is you got it I think he got
question yes yes so again I'm new to New
Hampshire but for I can only speak for
startup Colorado and in the state of
Colorado there are there are competitive
Eda and SBA grants that require you that
are that are out there specifically the
build back better Grant as well as the
built to scale Grant these are really
good grants that are available for a
catalyst to get this stuff going they
require matching funds which is 100%
required and and needed um in terms of
of startup Colorado's model only about
20% of our total operating funds came
from the state of Colorado and
everything else came from from federal
and private um individual donors however
we did not raise a fund to make
investments into startups we just did
the startup ecosystem development work
to get the resources going collaboration
with multiple sbdc score a lot of these
other accelerator programs co-working
spaces to get everyone kind of rowing in
the same boat to share that Dill flow
Scott mentioned that there's there's
money here to for in terms of investors
they're ready to write a check they just
say there's not enough Dill flow there's
not enough companies that are ready to
meet their investment thesis to receive
those funds so they're they're that
investment those investment dollars are
being sent to other
states um I hope that answers okay we
got one more question and then we're
gonna or two more questions and we'll
wrap it up okay
re thank you um I just had a question
one of the members to sit on the
commission is from the Department of
Business and economic Affairs and that
seems to be the best fit in state
government for for the tech Alliance to
interface with is there a position in
the ba that focuses on Startup the
startup ecosystem and VC and all that
because that seems to be the best place
for
it it's a good question uh I think
broadly there are a there is a position
or positions that work you know there
are people at ba who work with the tech
Alliance and who sit on the government
Affairs committee um and but
specifically just focused on Startup I
don't want to speak for the Bea but as
far as I know that specific position
does not
exist okay
representative
Burrows
yes just I was about to say your first
name and I said That's supposed to be
rude okay just a quick question you
talked about um you know private funding
have in your experience in other states
have have they ever included not just
money for the startup but for housing
has that ever been done
anywhere yes it's I mean there's models
all over the country but um from what
I've worked with it's been separate
entities that have you know economic
development is such a large umbrella and
Colorado did a really good job about
finding folks who who were experts in
each of those lanes and collaborating
with one another um in my experience it
what they weren't convoluted or together
in terms of a fund that would offer us
incentives but in New Hampshire I think
that would be a good way to go to make
sure that you could get the people that
you need and just to clarify we're not
asking I don't think for Scott um
correct me if I'm wrong but it based on
the bill and my conversations we're not
asking for the state to run and and
house this and fund it 100% we're asking
for collaboration partnership
yeah okay great thank you very much
thank you all right having no more cards
we'll close the public
hearing and then open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill
333 and I see the prime sponsor here and
a senator Carson you have a card
or
okay
great we we're running behind so we'll
just get going and do it I always am a
little hesitant Mr chairman to say I'll
be quick because usually you end up
taking an hour so um hopefully I'll be
in this committee
today nothing is
easy okay good morning Mr chairman and
good morning members of the House
Commerce Committee my name is Sharon
Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of London da Hudson
and Auburn and I have for your
consideration today Senate Bill 333
relative to access to financial services
for miners in legal custody or
Guardianship and relative to the board
of directors of mutual Banks and mutual
holding companies um Mr chairman uh I
think for the record I should declare
that I am an officer of the New
Hampshire um adoptive um Foster and
adoptive parents Association and I've uh
worked I've been on that Association for
a few years now and we work to uh
support foster children um adopt
children and children who have been
adopted from uh our state system and in
a lot of the work that we've done we
disco I discovered that foster children
that are working part-time jobs do not
have access to a bank account so um I
had a meeting with our state's banking
Department um over a year ago and we
started discussing how can we create um
a program that would allow these kids
who are working to start banking some
money rather than just um depending on
somebody else to do them do it for them
I think it's in a very important part of
uh Independence and it's something that
we'd like to Foster in children um
because sooner or later they're going to
age out of our system and the sooner
that they learn about money and how to
handle money the better off they'll
be so this bill does two things it
enables a minor over the age of 16 who
is in the legal care of HHS um to open a
checking or savings account at a bank or
credit union and it permits State
chartered Banks to have a majority and
secondly it permits State Charters Banks
to have a majority of directors residing
in New Hampshire or neighboring states
the first section of Senate Bill 333
Revol resolves challenges faced by
Foster Care youths who may have a job
and looking for ways to manage their
funds but do not have an adult in their
lives to co-sign to enable them to open
a checking or savings account this
impacts a very narrow youth a group of
young adults in the state cares and
enables them to have access to limited
Financial Services to help them Achieve
Financial stability and improve their
financial literacy the second section of
the bill assists State chartered Banks
and appointing qualified directors who
are in close-knit communities located
along the border and uh Senate Bill 333
was developed collaboratively with the
banking industry and the Department of
Health and Human Services and banking
Department respectively on each section
of the bill um I would also like to
publicly thank the New Hampshire banking
Department um and the bankers
Association for all their hard work they
really pulled Bankers together to work
on the issue of these kids being able to
have their own bank accounts so again
I'd like to thank them publicly and at
this point I am going to conclude my
testimony and I will try to answer
questions but there are folks here from
the banking department and uh from uh
the bankers Association to answer
questions all right thank you Senator
and would you take one question yes I
will I'll try yes thank you I just want
to make sure I understand the context
it's I never thought of this so children
that have a parent or Guardian that are
16 or older can open bank accounts but
these kids cannot that is correct
because you have to have because they're
considered to be minors and they can't
they can't sign for it themselves so
you've got to have an adult and
oftentimes foster parents um they don't
want that
responsibility um and their parents
they're there could be reasons why
they're not we don't know why there's a
variety of difference why they're not
with their legal parents so they're just
caught in this limbo and you'd be
surprised um we we talk a lot with um
older kids that are in foster care they
want to learn about money they want to
learn how to manage money they want to
learn about how do I save for my
retirement because if you think about it
many of these kids are pulled from their
homes and they've lost whatever security
that they had and security becomes
really a very important issue for these
kids and I see this as empowering it's
putting them on a path for Independence
they can save for college they can do
what whatever they want with it but it's
their money and they should have access
to it quick followup one follow do you
have happen to know about how many
children are impacted by this um oh and
we have well over a thousand children
but um according to the last statistic I
had this would affect fewer than 400 um
these are kids that are uh you know 16
or
older representative
spear thank you uh you pied 16 years old
to be in this and I remember being as a
kid you know we start earning money at
around 14 so I'm wondering why you pick
16 as opposed to a lower age actually um
thank you for that question that was an
age that was determined by the
bankers um so I I mean they're going to
be coming up and I think that would be a
good question to ask
them all right thank you very much for
your testimony thank you very much for
Mr chairman thank you and uh we'll call
Hil from New Hampshire Bankers
Association maybe you can answer that
us good morning I think it's still
morning right good morning uh chairman
honorable members of the House Commerce
Committee for the record my name is Ryan
hail vice president government relations
for the New Hampshire Bankers
Association we represent 40 member banks
here in New Hampshire that employ
roughly 6,000 employees um we do come
before the committee in strong support
of Senate Bill 333 and thank the sponsor
Senator Carson for introducing this very
important piece of legislation um I
won't get into my testimony because I
think the sponsor did an amazing job
highlighting um what this bill does and
the importance of it it does enable uh
Banks to open accounts for this very
small population of Youth uh in foster
care that do not have an adult in their
lives to co-sign on that account which
is considered a contract um this would
allow them to go in open that account um
to um then Access Financial Services
mainly bank and savings account and
starts them on a path to financial
stability um it's extremely important
that they have that opportunity the
second part of the of the bill would
open up and allow our state Charter
Banks to um have a majority of their
directors board of directors either
residing here in Hampshire or in
neighboring states like employers it's
tough to find um uh employees um it's
tough to find directors with specific
backgrounds and expertise so opening it
up to allowing uh a majority of those
directors to be not just New Hampshire
residents but residents uh in
surrounding states allows them to
brought them that net especially when it
comes to areas like cyber security um uh
right now the current requirement is a
majority just in New Hampshire this is
is uh especially important for our
members along the borders of our state
um some of them have border directors
that live in the other state but spend
most of working in New Hampshire owning
businesses here in New Hampshire so I'll
I'll conclude my testimony oh before I
conclude my testimony I would like to
thank both the Department of Health and
Human Services and the banking
department for their collaboration and
work on this um as the sponsor said this
is this was something that worked with
both departments in the fall to come up
with the language that is before you
today um so I would urge in conclusion
would urge the committee uh to support
uh Senate Bill 333 and I'm happy to take
any questions and and yeah the number 16
would you have any opposition to
lowering that to 14 that seems to make
sense so I'll defer to um Department of
Health and Human Services and our work
with uh the department they were the
ones that came up with the age 16 and 17
um so I will defer to them I believe
they are here um and prepared to testify
and answer any questions thank you
you're
welcome yes thank you uh one of the
things that I'm concerned about is that
when you have teenagers who may not have
a parent to be able to advise them in
this is fees and I was wondering if it
would be possible I mean this is just a
small group of people if we wrote in the
bill that they would not be subject to
any fees related to the account I mean
certainly penalties but fees because
sometimes you can have a an account
drained because of fees mhm and if
they're not getting advice from a parent
we the bank may want to consider that
yep thank you for that thank you for
that question and um you know banks have
different programs a lot of banks um do
have programs they have um what are
called Bank on um uh certified programs
that do for they do wave um they do wave
fees or don't charge fees it's to help
Bank the unbanked um to make easier
access but I can take that just would be
until they reach age of 18 even so that
they became
yeah great oh representa ton uh just a
quick question going uh to the point he
just made uh the Savings Bank of Walpole
and Mascoma bank had in in my experience
when my children were miners
they had special accounts uh that didn't
charge fees would this kind of would
this be that kind of account uh I just
is it the same Paradigm is that what the
thinking here is or if you could just
clarify if you know if you could clarify
that'd be
great yeah I mean I I think it depends
on you know each bank has different
products that they offer um you know we
would have to go back and talk to our
members to see what type you know you
know again this is enabling legislation
it would allow the bank to um if they
chose to bank the this population we do
have a couple members that have
expressed interest unfortunately the
banker that uh um testified and the
Senate wasn't able to um join us today
um he would be able to speak to the
services that he provides and the types
of accounts that he envisioned I can go
back to him and and ask those questions
and bring it back to the
committee I yeah just get his written
statement to the senate or whatever did
said of the Senate and have that sent to
great represent W CL excuse me thank you
Mr chair and thank you for being here
today um so lines 10 11 and 12 um says
the minor shall be responsible for
paying all banking related costs
associated with checking or savings
accounts and shall be liable for any and
all penalties should he or she violate a
banking agreement I know when my
children um were 13 they all um did line
field lining and got paid for it and at
that point um with a parent signature
they could have their own account and 35
years later they still have the same
account so um I for these children it's
a little bit different because they
don't have parents to advise them um and
I think those those fees should be waved
and so that is 10 11 and 12 and would
probably need to have an amendment thank
you
okay thank you very much thank
you uh John
Williams
and attorne attorney Lorie
young chairman hunt and members of the
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
for the record my name is John Williams
I'm the legislative director for health
and services and with me today is good
morning I'm Attorney Laura young I'm
litigation Council for the Department
Health and Human Services and we we are
here in support of senel 333 uh we in
fact worked with Senator Carson with the
New Hampshire Bank Association Mr hail
uh Miss Rooney um Excuse Me Miss Merill
uh and and others and and some
coordinated Outreach for collaboration
with the banking department so in uh
spirit of what happened yesterday I
thought it was the most absolutely
fascinating um hearing ever had when
asked to being able to tell something in
a story
format
so well I I cannot top yesterday that
truly by far was my favorite uh public
hearing so far today but I do have with
me attorney Lori Young uh who who's also
an attorney like like myself and if you
can indulge with a about a two-minute
story she can actually give you a quick
little story on this one as well we like
real life stories I was told of this
when I walked in the room so this is uh
as attorneys this is what we do so I
want you to imagine uh we're we're going
to stick with the name Johnny I
understand that was a favorite yesterday
name uh so we have little Johnny uh he
is in foster care because he is an
orphan he is 16 years old that means he
has no parent that could sign for any
kind of contract like a bank account uh
as part of Johnny's team because what
you have to imagine is for an individual
in foster care for a kid they actually
have a whole team behind them they have
not only their foster parents they have
their assigned social worker they often
have other parties at the table we're
very fortunate in New Hampshire to have
many stakeholders uh that come to the
table whether it's educational whether
it is therapeutic but you have to
imagine uh when you're thinking of this
that Johnny has a whole team behind him
he's 16 when they talk about his goals
Johnny says you know what I really want
to go to this basketball camp but it's
in Massachusetts our normal scholarships
don't cover it I can get a little bit of
this I've looked into it because part of
his goals for Independent Living because
every child has their own goals is that
he sets a goal of what he wants to do so
he decides he wants to go to basketball
camp he wants to be in the NBA I know
most of you are NBAs but he wants to be
in the NBA so he decides he wants to go
to basketball camp that costs around
$1,500 they decide said you know what
this would be a really good Independent
Living goal you can work towards this we
agree as a team at the table that going
you know going to work and getting a job
would be great for you and then having a
bank account as it stands right now
Johnny if he wanted to save he'd have to
keep he had to pay fees to cash a check
and then he'd have to just store that
cash underneath a mattress and a piggy
bank what you want but you think about
that that's not only fee driven but it's
also um it's just a little ludicrous
when we think about how cashless as a
society we are that he'd have to just
store this so now with this bill he now
has the department the team goes to the
department and says we agree as a team
that this is appropriate for him to have
a bank account uh we would like to help
him get a job and do that department
puts through the bill um in writing that
we we consent to that they go to the
bank with his foster parents or his
social worker whichever one Johnny
chooses uh to help him open the bill
he's able to get a job we're going to go
with Market Basket because I think most
of us in New Hampshire started their
careers at Market Basket he gets the bow
tie he gets to um do his thing and he
works and he's able to save that amount
what's important though that you notice
in the bills I said, 1500 we're not
talking 3,000 5,000 that's because
Johnny is a foster child and an orphan
he is on State Medicaid I want to point
that out because we do have asset
limitations for that and that's
something that we put purposefully into
this bill because as much as we want
Johnny to have a huge nest egg in the
future without other safeguards uh he
could not not you know have a bank
account for that so that's something
that as a department we would have to be
Case by case Johnny we know is on
Medicaid he can't have over $2,000 in
his bank account so that would be part
of our consent we consent to Johnny
having a bank account and we will work
with him to make sure it's not over
$2,000 now the part of the reason the
team agreed to this again the team
talked about his goal we knew that he
was going to spend that he was going to
you know raise it and then spend it get
it low we're okay with that we agree
with that so as a mentality as a team
it's an educational goal independent
living and then also we do teach our
foster kids as part of our independent
living goals financial literacy it is
very hard to teach that in a vacuum
without actually it's very different to
do a pretend checkbook than our own
checkbook to have a debit card versus a
pretend one this would take it a step
further in preparing our foster youth
for Independence in a controlled way
where we consent or and we put in the
bill purposefully if the Foster youth
the team does not agree with him having
a bank account he can go court that we
put that in that is an option as well
and the court can decide um so that
gives an extra layer of protection and
also I think that's also aign of
Independence to the youth says I hear
you as a team I disagree I'm going to go
to court and then you have court
protections involved like Court
appointing Council in cassa and a g so
you just to have just so the committee
knows there are layers built in to that
as well uh and so now Johnny can go to
basketball camp we're going to say he
made it to the NBA New Hampshire
representing and um and and it's all
because he was able to have a bank
account and go to subn Camp wow
excellent I have a distinct feeling that
was
fiction but uh represent Ammon has a
question just a question about the
$2,000 cap what happens if Johnny earns
another $10 over 2,000 what happens if
he tries to deposit that into the
account just curious yeah so we we are
with and that's one thing that the
consent it can be over I think part of
the financial literacy is Al the team
whether it's the Foster or the social
social worker monitoring the account and
making sure and in communication but I
think if he were to go over that we
would then have to withdraw our consent
and have to come up with a spin down
plan and that's very common for someone
benefits that we have to have a spin
down plan you have 30 days to spin down
so that you don't lose your benefits but
that this is but this is again I I
highlight that because that's why it's
important for the Department to consent
not every kid is ready for this just
like you talked about your own kids you
wait until you knew your k was ready for
it are you that you didn't know you had
to be on the bank statement yourself
getting them that's the same mentality
here about consent and then also the
court approval is making sure we have
the conversation with the kid a
16-year-old and I want to answer that
question as well about why we chose 16
if that's why um that we we know there's
that maturity and that expectation and
that's clear from the part it was a
Department's choice to choose the age of
16 internally felt that was an
appropriate age for this first step of
this bill it's for around 400 Foster
youth that's a manageable number to see
how many are interested in this and then
go from there this was a good number
when talking to the cpsws and internally
that this was around the time when we're
seeing kids want to work anyway it's
also the time of driving for example
being able to go um to a job that's a
common goal is wanting to buy a car for
example um and so we felt 16 was a good
starting point based on internal
discussions with maturity level Foster
Youth and interest and those who are
currently interested I'm
working represent
buam thank you for taking my question
um what about the foster parents I mean
the foster parents could they have
access to this
account it would be the department that
consents to it just like a parent so we
think they would they would not be able
to go into a bank and withdraw money
because they would not be on the account
the depart you can think of the
department is the the parent if you well
okay
thanks um I can't believe I'm going to
do this but did you see that 60-minute
story a couple weeks ago about these
foster kids who had no parents and that
the state was taking uh Medicare
Medicare
money it was social was it Social
Security or medic it was Social Security
money did you see that and repm Hunt um
there's actually a bill currently uh in
the house on that issue it was sponsored
by represent Mary Jane walner it's
heading over to the Senate on that very
issue and we've been provided a sum of
money for a consultant to come in to
help design what that process would look
like here in New Hampshire so that was
brilliant but this bill has nothing to
do with taking anything this is giving
to people and again we chose very
carefully the scenario of Johnny because
Johnny is going to maintain just like
represent post children uh that account
until age 34 and then run for the uh
House of Representatives and then
sometime be serving on well I was I was
more worried that that this $2,000 cap
that if that money was come available
you know that I get but I guess it
18 yeah when someone has Social Security
benefits um that rep pay fund would be
if someone only has a representative pay
and that's that's who takes the money on
behalf of another person who's
incapacitated by age if you will for
children uh then when that
incapacitation is over so if a child is
merely incapacitated because of as soon
as they are not incapacitated that money
goes to Social Security and then Social
Security decides where it goes whether
it needs to be a new rep pay because
there's a incapacity problem other than
age or what's more common is it's age 18
they send the the money directly to I
just want to make sure that that money
can go into this account that this
account that he have yes that's correct
when they're 18 um they the Department's
name would come off um and then yes they
would have a bank account to receive
money I feel much better about it then
good story
thank you very much and and thank you
and also uh Senator Carson and you uh
represent hun as one of co-sponsor Bill
I see there's another question that was
yeah representative pelli then
representative post again thank you for
the story My question is so would the
department oversee how the money is
being saved and what Johnny wants to do
with it is there any guidance on that or
he's free to do whatever whatever B bet
on DraftKings or do whatever wants with
it or or is there some guidance as to
what what to do with it so this goes
back into the consent and the team
mentality that we're relying on and that
is something we have thought of um and
that's why we wanted to narrow it to age
16 to start out and we all wanted to
have a narrow number because this would
be their bank account uh that is and it
would require monitoring by the team and
be what we consider an inment
independent living goal and it would be
something that we'd have to meet on but
it would be their bank account and just
as a 16-year-old unless mom and dad is
right there next to them would be able
to spend it yes they would be able to
spend
it and representative
post yes thank you um my question is
well my statement is that when I did
this with my children I was on their
bank account I could
withdraw and I had that ability to do it
although I never did
um however with foster children are they
still being placed in different families
and how would that affect a bank account
if a foster family um you know is
supporting him with that bank account so
the Foster family would not be on the
bank account be the department and you
are correct it you know it does the
Foster family there are transitions
throughout uh whether it's going you
know from home to home or are going in
and out of different placements I the
department would be on the bank account
not foster parents now you could have a
situation that one Foster family was
much more involved for example than a
new one but again that's why I go back
to each each child has a team behind
them um that does not completely change
with a new placement and that would be
part of their goals that would follow
them if I could follow up further
question me
inquire thank you um so
often people who work for the state
don't stay there and then they would
have to get another person to fill that
so would that be um the bank account has
to again be
done with someone else no it it would um
much like I think of the professional
fiduciary um professional fiduciaries
that we have it's a organizational it's
not an independent name
thank you and and uh chairman hun if I
could just follow up on a general you
know theme here in response to the
several questions that have been asked
as Senator Carson mentioned when she
introduced the bill we really focus on
financial literacy and these kids are
caught in a situation where they have no
ability no ability to getting a bank
account like all children whose brains
are developing they're going to make
some good choices and bad choices this
is that time for them to learn those
choices and hopefully you're going to
make better choices and worse choices so
please consider that when you're
actually contemplating on getting the
Weeds on the various different scenarios
in the bill and we strongly would
abdicate not to use that money for
DraftKings or anything like
that right we call it the Dignity of
choice um these kids they're getting
into adul who they have the Dignity of
making choices uh you know some choices
are going to be worse than others but
they deserve the chance to make their
own
choices okay well representative
R thank you thanks for taking my
question or comment I mean fundamentally
this is money that these kids are going
to earn so it's really their money and
you're helping them by advising them as
to best choices and best management
practices so it seems like yeah they
even though they're minors that they
really have ownership in this but
obviously you know because of issues
they have they may need guidance that's
right and again that goes back to we're
not we're not saying we'll consent for
every single one it really it's a case
by case basis of which kid is ready for
this and whether it's an appropriate
goal uh for that
child great thank you very much uh
having no more cards we will close the
public
hearing and on to our final one this
morning cville 502 relative to the
scanning of non driver identification
cards by real estate
brokers we just covered everything today
didn't
we
I and it's still morning
it's Mr chairman I I I I completely
understand this is the sixth bill that
I've testified on this morning so and
it's the last and then I've got hearings
thisno going great so uh
again good morning uh Mr chairman and
members of house Commerce uh for the
record my name is Sharon Carson and I
have the pleasure of representing Senate
District 14 comprising the towns of
London Dair Hudson and Auburn and I have
for your consideration this morning
Senate Bill 502 relative to the scanning
of non- drivers identification cards by
real estate brokers um this legislation
is Seeking a statutory change to RSA 2
uh colon 12 section X or relative to the
electronic sharing of a driver's license
the intent of the legislation is to
combat an uptick in scammers posing as
land owners and asking a real estate
agent to list the property the scam
operates in the following manner an
individual will file uh will claim to be
from out of state and looking to sell a
property quickly in some cases the
scammers have research the history of
the property and have a great deal of
information which can make the request
appear authentic there have been cases
where deposits from buyers were placed
in escrow before the scam was discovered
this is prevalent in the northern part
of the state where vacant land is more
um more prevalent and it is something
that is happening across the country
with greater frequency um I had read an
article about um this type of situation
in Greenwich Connecticut where um a
gentleman had inherited not only his
house but his family's house but a plot
of land that was next to it and he kept
that Land open because um he was hoping
to get leave it to one of his children
and they could build a house there um he
was currently living in Florida and uh
he got a phone call from a neighbor
saying you sold the land and he was like
no I didn't um somebody had pretended to
be him sold that piece of land to an
unsuspecting buyer and uh they dug a
foundation and they were actually in the
process of building a home and this is
in Greenwich Connecticut um very very
expensive uh place to live so to say the
least um he flew up and he confronted
the people people that were there it got
an attorney people were arrested and
eventually they discovered that someone
had scammed uh these folks um and the
people that actually bought the property
and paid to have a house put there they
were now out of quite a bit of money
because they did not purchase legal
title to the land so this is the type of
situation that this legislation is
trying to prevent um under current law
real estate lies are prohibited from
asking from for these buyers to send a
copy or photograph of the license to
authenticate their identity currently
RSA
26312 prohibits the electronic storage
of a driver's license unless
specifically Exempted by Statute or
regulation this bill seeks to add a
small exemption to the existing statute
for Real Estate lenses
this bill prohibits retaining the
scanned license beyond the closing date
of the transaction or when requested by
the holders of the driver's license
currently Pond broker scrap dealer scrap
metal dealers or secondhand dealers are
exempt in statute while financial
institutions insurance and other
legitimate businesses which deal with
motor uh vehicles are exempt in the
rules Senate Bill 502 would enable real
estate licenses to have a similar
limited
exemption um the leaders from the uh I
hope someone's here from the New
Hampshire Association of reers Realtors
to provide additional qu uh information
and can answer any questions and they
were uh involved in creating the
language in advancing the legislation
and at this point Mr chairman I will
conclude my testimony I will try to
answer any questions but the Realtors
are here and hopefully they can answer
the questions uh we have a real for
repres so this is sort of a would you
believe less of a question you don't
have to go to Greenwich Connecticut in
chesher County uh which is not
particularly rural but not particularly
developed uh we have had a Spate of
these in the last six months and we
actually had and your example is good
but I I want to bring it right home to
good old Winchester New Hampshire
Winchester New Hampshire has a very
popular not to be confused with
Greenwich not to be confused with
grenwich but if you buy lakefront
property anywhere including
Winchester um you can it's expensive so
we had a transfer a sale the agent
listed the property the scenario atat
Town seller a morphous name you know
like the John be hunt Memorial trust or
something like that and somebody called
and said yeah that's me and uh they
listed the property and the first cash
offer that came along they
took and interestingly the seller turned
down higher offers for more money
because they involved time and mortgages
and things but that cash offer looked
really good to close in 10 days and uh
so for
$650,000 they closed on a piece of
lakefront property in on Forest Lake and
Winchester and it was a real shock to
the guy who went to build his house to
find out that he didn't own it that it
had never the real seller had never sold
the property these people doing title
they didn't do it to get a title they
did they the guy forged it was
completely forged so the John but but
Title Insurance in these both these
cases the person didn't buy title
insurance they they they they were it
was the title insurance would not have
covered them from knowing fraud is my
understanding so and but that but they
don't go away just because you get
caught on one street we had the exact
same scenario where a builder that my
company represents said I'm going to
throw in a lowball offer and see what
they say on some building Lots not more
than a mile away and to the astonishment
of absolutely everyone in my office the
seller so-called agreed to this offer
and it was the title comp we happen to
use the same title company that had been
scammed by these people 30 days earlier
so this is really prevalent and I would
like to make one other observation about
the the LI the driver's license issue
this is a health and safety issue for
Real Estate
practitioners there are and you didn't
mention that it's not really in the bill
but it has been a there are it is not
unusual and I'm going to be very sexist
here and say for uh
women to go and take showings on
properties in the evening and at night
with people that they don't know and in
retrospect you would say why did you do
that um but it happens it's a health and
safety issue and it is recommended in
realtor training that you should verify
who you're showing property to but
particularly if you know after 45 years
nothing surprises you but when you're
new and excited and you have your first
or second buyer and they say I want to
meet you out at the property at
6:00 uh at night on a
Wednesday and it's out on the back end
of nowhere uh and if you don't come back
or you don't nobody knows who you met
that's a problem and it has you should
be the agents should be able to scan
these licenses for that reason as
well representative Sullivan that's a
would you believe yes
thank you um just to clarify
so is this some so when when somebody
goes to buy a a property now are they
checking the identity of of people now
or is that like a you choose to check
the identity um thank you for the
question I'm not a real estate person
the Realtors are here and they would be
able to answer that question if it's
required um this is really just an
attempt to stop people um and
establishing really the identity of
someone who's selling a piece of
property um that they are the actual
person um we know it's easy to Fig uh to
forge a document but it can be a little
more difficult to forge a driver's
license and you can check a driver's
license as well yeah so yeah I was just
looking because it says may and and it
sounds like it might be optional you're
going to leave it up to them I mean I
kind of shy away from Sha because that
means every single time and it could be
you're selling you know your brother is
selling the property and you know your
brother so you know who it is so you
wouldn't do something like that you
wouldn't require it so you just want to
give some discretion representative gry
has a question yeah one of the concerns
I have on here and it talked about in in
line 25 it talk you should not retain
the scan license for a period of longer
than the closing date and and if I would
think if it was fraud you'd probably
want to have that license longer than
the closing date because once the
license the scan is gone you can't
figure out who that person is if they
did have a fake license or a fake ID
would putting something in here like
maybe 6 months beyond the closing or a
year beyond the closing in case we found
out that it was fraudulently purchased
that at least we have a photo of that
person um thank you for that question um
that's an interesting point when this
was crafted I I know my concerns were
about privacy and our and protecting the
driver driver's license we use our
driver's license for so many things
today um and we do have a constitutional
amendment concerning privacy and if you
put in a section for them to hold it
then you're going to have to put in what
are their criteria how are they going to
hold it how is that going to be uh
maintained the security around it and
then you're going to have to have
legislation well if there's a breach of
security what are you going to do this
is I I it could at some point if they
decide that's what they want to do but
for me this was a first step in giving
them a tool and and the way that I
phrase it it's a tool in the toolbox for
realtors um so I I understand your
concerns representative um I'm I was
just concerned about privacy
issues so I take the opposite point of
view um in the vacation rental business
this is a huge problem people take take
the real estate listing of the house M
and put it up on
Airbnb and people start you know sending
monies and and both try to book and then
and uh you know with that through that
to that property when it turns out they
didn't really own it um and both my I
use verbo but you knowb they all now
promised well that if you get scam like
that they'll find you another place you
know they they'll try to cover it but it
is a huge issue so the reason why I say
I take a different point of view is that
um I I myself uh we we were always
worried about whether we had an age
requirement in the vacation and you know
you're 30 years old so we ask you to
prove it by sending you a sending us a
copy of your driver's
license and yes I still have all those
driver's license attached to the form
because I staple it to the to the thing
and there it is so I am absolutely aware
that I am breaking this statute and but
I would say is is that what what we need
to review and I and I would not
necessarily delay this issue but I I've
always being aware of this problem is
that the customer has a right to say no
I'm not going to give you my driver's
license in that case then we just don't
do the
deal but that if the customer is willing
to give the driver's license they have
to know that that there is a potential
that that license that copy is not going
to get
destroyed they have to know
that having said that I agree with what
I was about to say the same thing you
know representative grassy is talking
about which is when do you at what point
do you destroy that credit card in my
case it would be when the renter shows
up and clearly they're over 30 or we
profile them and see that they're over
30 then we're not worried about it but
at the same time I've heard you know of
all these scams that yeah I think that
to to hold the person who requested it
and was given it by the
customer and to hold them responsible to
say that they need to you know turn it
over and they need to burn it and no
come on I'm going to hold on to it as
long as I'm I can be worried that on my
exposure to that person not being who
they were so there is something that I
would think we might want to look at and
and in terms of you know that this this
issue isn't just this I mean I guess
technically U vacation rentals is a real
estate real estate issue um but you know
there's there's probably a lot of cases
I mean I had one was the classic one was
every time I um at my soab dealer in
motor they when I G they gave me a loner
they took a copy of my driver's license
and they stuck it in their folder yeah
okay now did you say did I ever ask for
it back no because the next time I come
they don't have to make another copy
they've already got it
but clearly that violated the law Mr
chairman um I I think that that a number
of points have been raised about this
and I'm going to leave it up to the
collective wisdom of this committee if
you want them to be able to hold it
that's fine I'm I'm not going to
complain about it I would not uh you
know hold this up I I do think it's
extremely important um we're dealing as
the representative said with a lot of
these things that are happening that
plus people who are squ
right in properties so um okay you want
have a last
question just on the issue of what's
called non-public information
NPI um most of I know all of the lenders
if you deal with lender owned properties
and those kinds of things
foreclosures There are rules on handling
and I think the association may actually
have rules on it and Professional
Standards regarding non-public
information so
um you
know my only point is there is on on the
on the professional side of it if you
belong to the realtor Association which
all lenses do not um nor do they have to
uh but there are there are again there
are there's professional training and
constraints on what are going to do with
that
nonpublic information and um obviously
people are going to screw up no matter
what you do but I would say I agree with
the six months and I wouldn't want to
hold this up over it either right okay
thank you very much thank you very much
Mr chairman okay
Sarah all I'm representing the New
Hampshire
I do not have a well I I can share lots
of stories
actually um but I think my my name is
Sarah Holland I'm the vice chair of
public policy for the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors um I am a
practicing associate broker um and an
educator in the real estate space as
well um I think you all have done a
wonderful job having this conversation
um before my testimony and it
encompassed a lot of what I was going to
say um how this came about was one of
our
um fellow lies our colleagues um had a
conversation someone called and said
that they were the son of a former
client they were saying all the right
things Spidey senses went up they were
like I'm not really sure I should
probably ask for some identification
just to make sure this leny spoke with
um a friend of theirs who happened to be
a member of the State Police they said
Hold up you can't ask for and retain
this driver's license information
so that's where all of this kind of came
about in addition to just the safety
aspect of it as well we would really
like for this to be in place um and to
add some more kind of Hometown stories
there's one particular parcel in The
Lakes Region that has been targeted
multiple times by scammers um and it's
actually owned by a a fraud attorney
which is interesting perfect so um yeah
so everybody knows that this is kind of
the place but a number of Agents have
kind of gone through the motions of
getting this almost listed or actually
listed before they realize that this was
the case um and when you get further
down the you know the transaction
process from contract to close there are
some steps that can be taken tidal is
doing a really good job now knowing that
these scams are going on to kind of make
sure that they're not getting through
closing um and identifying these parties
lenders same way but that's also on just
the Buy side not on the cell side which
is where the scammers are um so we kind
of want to head it off right at the
beginning if we could so yeah happy to
answer any questions that you
have I think we're all set perfect I
think we're hungry thank you all thank
you very much okay having no more uh
cards we will close the public
1:15
e
are
you I'm well you tell me how I am in
about 15 minutes
okay yeah I'm sorry I had to dash out
but I nice to see
you yeah I like you know I I I have been
years
e
was
it's yeah Badger company okay uh I don't
see okay we'll open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill
97 and here from the prime sponsor who's
already in place and ready to go thank
you Mr chairman uh I'm Senator David
Waters from District Ford to introduce
Senate Bill 97 relative to the use of
animals and product testing and it may
seem like deja vu all over again Mr
chairman and or maybe a long winding
road but I think this time we really gut
it on this bill through a lot of
iterations but um but to get to get to
the bill um this bill uh is puts some
guard rails of Regulation around animal
in product testing and um what's why we
need to do this is because we want want
to make sure that New Hampshire has
appropriate Statute in place should
there be animal testing that might go
beyond the bounds of what uh is
appropriate under Federal legislation
and secondly it's important to do
because while there is some Federal
Regulation on it they do not enforce
federal statute within States so in a
lot of Regulation we also have um you
know kind of parallel concomitant within
the state I think that this bill comes
to you in a spirit of what is uh
practical and what uh is appropriate for
animal protection um you know I think
for those have been around for a while
we look back to the commitment for
animals in this state I I think Bob
Smith Senator Bob Smith when he was a
representative and a senator um he
carried an animal protections as one of
his main issues uh and then after you
know Jud Greg as as well and um you know
and particularly with the dogs and
domestic pets of Senator Bradley so
there's just such a tradition here
making sure that we have the appropriate
Protections in place so um to look at
page two is where the heart of the uh
bill is um and it says
uh don't use traditional animal test if
the alternative is
available or if it
meets um you know if if it can meet the
provisions of the exceptions that are um
provided and uh so what this will let us
do is to say that you know here are the
criteria but importantly listing on page
one the
exceptions um and just to turn to those
then you have your definition of
alternative test methods and this is not
something that we invented this is what
other states uh have and it outlines um
you know where alternative methods are
defined and then uh noting starting
online um 18 the exceptions that
sometimes a biomedical research uh if
there is not an appropriate alternative
then this that's what you you can
conduct the research uh you have your
definition of contract testing um uh
facility manufacturing traditional
animal test method um in particular in
the biomedical research um apparently I
had thought we had really made sure that
the
universities uh and colleges research
was covered by the language here I think
they want to tweak this to make sure
that the kind of testing they do um
would uh be appropriately recognized in
in the bill and the protection for
testing that simply must be done for
life- saving drugs and other other
reasons so I think you're going to hear
about a possible little Amendment there
and I think that that makes some
sense um what really uh you know as you
know there's been a lot of history on
this this bill a couple times and it was
retained in the Senate and what really
um kind of broke the Log Jam uh was on
page two that last paragraph we went
around and around on whether there would
be the attorney general or some other
agency would have enforcement or fines
or penalties and so on and then would we
have to create a recordkeeping registry
where the state would be responsible for
collecting the records of any lab or any
manufacturer or so on and what we came
up with with great advice from the
Attorney General's office uh and others
in HHS
too have a record keeping requirement
but it have it be on on the folks who
may be doing the testing to post whether
or not they're doing it and it would
just be on their website or otherwise
and to alert the public that that uh by
that means and I that that's really what
made this bill um possible that that
seemed a very reasonable approach uh to
take as to um how we had some assurance
that the the people would know if such
testing was taking place and that these
alternative test methods and traditional
test methods um criteria had been
followed so I know we're going to have
um Kurt Amberg here and some uh folks
representing um Dartmouth who can talk
more about it but I you know I would be
GL to take a couple questions but I
probably prefer to turn it over too but
go ahead representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
your testimony I just have a question on
uh it just popped into my head so
forgive
me uh does this apply to animal testing
in the womb so if if the animal let say
it's an embryo could could a
manufacturer still do testing on an
embryo would that fall under this the
statute you know I'm going to have to
leave it up to the expt I I can't
imagine I think so I can't imagine but I
co-sponsor yes go ahead you're tough Mr
chairman right my question is how many
companies are um doing animal testing do
you know is there a record of who's
who's for your question um as best did I
know and again Kurt will address this
there is no one current no no company
manufacturers currently doing it we
heard from folks like berts bees who
have made a corporate commission to uh
commitment to not use that and they
advertise that um but I think that the
uh inverse the of this is that um we
don't want New Hampshire to become a
target for a company that might wish to
start that testing because we don't have
the appropriate statutes in place um
certainly there is appr appropriate
testing that may be under undertaken in
the biomedic research and that's
important and that's why the the federal
statute the exemptions are there that
you know for for health and you know
whatever it may be that you really there
is no alternative then yes um those are
permitted and that but as far as the a
manufacturer or a Cosmetic Company um at
this point uh there is there there is
none
currently representative pus thank you
Mr chairman thank Senator Waters uh I
have a question you mentioned uh
the who would be doing the testing I
noticed uh line 18 to 27 says we know
what the the different types of testing
are my question is does it really matter
who is doing it by listing who we would
either include or exclude by accident
someone
um thanks for your question um I I think
that what we try what has tried to be
done in lines 18 through 29 here is to
provide that kind of coverage so you got
your
biomedical uh you got contract testing
facilities you got manufacturers I
mentioned cosmetic folks um and uh so
and then I think the traditional animal
test method kind of kind of sets the
criteria about what you would evalue who
who might be doing it so I I think this
is pretty comprehensive and again it is
kind of modeled on what the federal
agree thank you was that I'm sorry
anybody else I guess I guess I I'll play
a devil's advocate here go ahead
so as I read this recordkeeping thing y
so the recordkeeping thing is that we're
going to require anybody who
who who does do it right I guess we're
talk of Dartmouth Hitchcock if they do
do it they have to put on their web page
that they're doing this
testing thank you for the question yeah
so um after 2026 so they have some time
uh and uh note that there is an
exclusion here um for biomedical
research so every experiment conducted
at you know UNH Dartmouth wouldn't have
to be listed on the website because they
would be covered under the federal and
other requirements on the biomedical
definition here but if you're a
manufacturer a contract testing facility
if you begin to do this then you would
put on your website we are conducting
such and such
tests right so but it's it's still
limited
to uh some requirements of what the
processing being so so if I may Mr
chairman so you see in lines 17 18
number number and species of animals he
was on page two number of species of an
used type of number of alternative test
methods used the number of waivers used
and the purpose of the of the testing
for all methods so it's just it's a very
light touch really to that somebody can
check right so now I'm going to play
Devil's Advocate so why do we have to
say
uh um no manufacturer contractor shall
use a traditional animal test meth which
is appropriate alternative me so as long
as we we're not going to ban it we're
just going to say is if you are doing
it you you you as long as you put it on
your web page and tell everybody because
this is kind this public disclosure is I
assume intended to be sort of a public
embarrassment you know that that that
you're you you you might think it's
awkward to put on your web page that the
fact that you're testing animals thanks
for the question yeah I go ahead how you
yeah that's what I'm saying I said so
isn't that is that penalty enough for
someone who's for given that we have
nobody's doing this
now and somebody wants to come to New
Hampshire and start up a biotech
business or whatever and they you know
feel compelled to need to test animals
shouldn't we just be happy that we've
got this requirement that they have to
put it on their web page and and
publicly announce to everybody in the
world that that's what they're doing
thanks for the question I think that to
me it's not embar about public
embarrassment or anything I think what
it is is for us to um know that they
have checked the boxes that that if
there is no alternative method available
they're using the
traditional that's what that's what it
gets at we have all the exception for
alternative and they can just say we're
doing we're using X alternative method
on these animals for these purposes if
the alternative doesn't exist or they
have an exemption because of the you
know the things that are listed then
they'll say we're using traditional test
method these anal under such and such um
protocol and so uh it it is a light
touch but I think it's important because
it says to the folks coming in that um
you know we are we got an eye on this
you know that the state of New Hampshire
is interested in protecting Animal
Welfare I mean that is a very deep
tradition for us and this is um just to
say you know we're we're going to take
some appropriate caution to make sure
that uh the statute's being followed got
that's I think another thanks for the
question that I think is another reason
why the bill worked in the Senate
because it is silent on that because we
did not want to
involve that HHS or doj would have to
visit every website of every person in
the state looking for it it is public
information if a member of the
public such as you know I can imagine
human main society or sbca if they if
they're concerned about this and they
can look around the websites and uh and
and see who's doing what and um that I
think is if and if they think that they
that there is a violation I suppose it
could be called to the attention or I
would say of you know they could call it
to the attention of of the state but I
didn't want the state to be involved in
surveillance of everybody who's in
business in the state and uh I think we
often you know have have things that are
posted by by companies and um this see
seems to me be a a light touch and
appropriate way to put the
responsibility on the manufacturers to
let the public
know no it's it's it's untenable I mean
you I've never had a bill in which we
aren't going to identify who the
regulator
is you got to you got to know who's
you okay
afternoon good afternoon Mr chair
and members of the committee I'm Kurt
aronberg I'm the state director of the
Humane Society of the United
States and I'm here in favor of sb97 as
amended I want to thank Senator Waters
uh for his testimony I also want to
thank uh senator richardi from Bedford
who uh did a lot of work on this
bill uh a friend of animals in New
Hampshire um and I want to thank this
committee for hearing this bill again
and doing so much work uh on this bill
over the last couple of years so thank
you
um in terms of my testimony I furnished
written testimony to everyone we have
letters of support from some uh New
Hampshire
companies um this bill prohibits the
testing of products on on animals in New
Hampshire if there is a better way to do
it it's that
simple uh the original Bill had uh
Provisions for inspecting products that
came in from other states that's not in
this bill anymore uh the original Bill
had compliance through the Attorney
General's office which was deemed much
too expensive and honorous by many of
you
uh that's not in this bill anymore um
what is in this bill is a reporting
mechanism that allows us and all of the
people who love animals in New Hampshire
majority huge majority of people in this
state who love animals and support this
bill and support these kinds of uh
measures in this
state that you know the reporting
means that people like us who love
animals and monitor this we have a large
organization that is concerned about
this issue will'll make sure that this
law is enforced in this
state I'm happy to take any
questions so you're the regulating
agency
sure you mean no I mean seriously
seriously seriously um
we don't think it's a problem we want to
make sure it is not a problem we want to
set an example for human beings around
the world that they do not unnecessarily
have to cause suffering in animals it's
plain and simple we need your vote on
this thank
you okay we do have a question
representative wals who's a huge animal
lover thank you Mr chairman yes I am and
thank you for taking my question uh so
to our Chairman's very valid point
should you or someone discover that you
know once this Bill gets passed that yes
there is a company out there that is
going against this who would you bring
it to so do you know in other states who
the regulator is my my organization
alone has resources legal technical Etc
that could bring we could bring to bear
to make sure that that company was out
of business whether it was through
legal protest whatever it may be you
know we we will this bill is important
the to stop the cruel testing
unnecessary cruel testing on animals is
very important so what what my
organization has decided to do is you
know we will if if the state of New
Hampshire doesn't have the resources to
protect these animals we'll take that on
all we're asking is that you make sure
that we know what's going on and that
anyone who might be doing this to
animals has to tell us and if they're if
they're testing products and not testing
on animals fine um and and you know if
there is a small amendment to this bill
because you know we have been very clear
biomed research is not part of this bill
so if there is need to be a provision a
a slight language change to protect a
facility at
Dartmouth fine as long as that language
is very clear that it is only for biomed
research purposes we would be we would
be okay with that depending on what the
language actually
is
represent thank you Mr chair and I love
animals I just want to tell you that um
I have a dog I love my dog um is it a
bulldog it's a it's American
Staffordshire but yeah um there was a a
couple of recent news stories one the
federal government was paying for
research for beagles thousands and
thousands of beagles they were tying
them down and inflicting Sandfly larvae
on the dogs on their heads until it
drove the dogs insane and they were
released from the lab and went up for
adoption there's a big news story about
how those puppies were freed just so you
know
asked me to to if I was interested in
adopting one dog oh that's really good I
know those dogs yeah that's very Co that
pulled up my heart those dogs I do know
those dogs actually that's really good
um but I want to follow up because of it
could be a potential loophole um there
there are also recent stories about uh
the there's new technology where they
can grow animals in like a plastic bag
they can grow sheep in a plastic bag
right and well they could be a animal so
as a potential loophole for this um bill
that you're proposing does it Outlaw
testing on fetal animals on animals that
have not yet been born and uh just
question so the way I read this bill any
animal
any like any part of you would be part
of you would be contained as a part of
your person that if you're testing on
the
animal you're testing on the animal it's
pretty
it okay we're all set thank you thank
you very much appreciate it uh Joan
O'Brien from New Hampshire animal rights
League
good
afternoon you have to push the
button uh there you go um
I'm not Joan O'Brien oh okay no but I'm
speaking for Joan today because Joan has
um jury duty really so she asked me to
fill in for her so here I
am yeah I
know
that's anyway um so my name is Linda
Dion and I'm from Raymond New Hampshire
okay so Linda Diane
yes and
um so she wanted me to read this is it
okay if I read her testimony no problem
okay and I apologize for the paper it's
printed on I didn't realize that was
paper and my printer and uh I couldn't
see doing it over that would be a
waste so um chairman hunt um and
everybody else on the committee thank
you for letting me speak and on behalf
of the New Hampshire animal rights
League Joan is the president of the New
Hampshire animal rights league so on
behalf of the new hampsh animal right
League and rights league and our members
we respectfully request that the
committee support Senate Bill 97 to
prohibit product testing on animals when
an alternative test method can be used
this bill is another step forward in the
campaign to end the infliction of pain
and suffering on animals under the guise
of human protection many tests performed
on animals continue simply to comply
with regulations rather than from any
scientific value animals are burned
blinded scalded poisoned mutilated
starved and have sub substances forced
down their throat through tubes so that
the products we use every day can be
called
safe Senate Bill
97 will prevent any such unnecessary
tasks from taking place in New Hampshire
as you consider this bill note that
today April 2 24th happens to be world
day for laboratory animals I know isn't
that a coincidence
huh yeah since it's its Inception in
1979 World Daya lab animals has spurred
the global effort to Halt animal
suffering and substitute these
experiments with sophisticated
non-animal methods these changes cannot
come fast enough for the estimated
825,000 animals experimented on in the
United States every year this includes
roughly 72,000 monkeys
42 45,000 dogs and 13,000
cats if you add Birds mice rats and
fish species considered so important
unimportant that resourcers don't even
have to report how many they use the
number of animals used in experiments
each year is 10 in the tens of
millions in closing we hope that the
committee will support sb97 and in honor
of world day for lab animals we she Joan
would like to ask you to pledge to
purchase only crueltyfree cosmetics and
household
products and um thank you for your
consideration and I would just like to
say a little bit um I've been around a
long time I did a lot of um letter
writing in the 1980s about product
testing on animals the cruelty and
everything that was before computers
letter writing um and a lot of progress
has been made but this will
this will be a little bit more progress
especially for New Hampshire and that's
what we need and uh I'd also like to say
that um getting products that are that
are crueltyfree is not that difficult
anymore like in the 80s I used to have
to send away for products that weren't
tested on animals now even Dove has the
little uh bunny logo so you can buy all
of Dove products and um even the dollar
and a lot of people are concerned that
costs more even in the dollar store you
can find a lot of Cruelty
products amazing yeah when it says
825 where where is all this testing
occurring um in labs around the country
yeah like do you know which states or
don't have this law or where where where
where is a where are where are all these
testings occurring I just I'm shocked
yeah I don't have the answer I haven't
been following it that closely maybe
Kurt has it yeah I think Kurt might or
someone else might have that information
great I mean yeah probably in the New
York I think Boston Harvard has
Labs
yeah
es yeah a train a train or truck monkeys
this wasn't a
movie so it is it's a very cruel thing
and
unnecessary most right well thank you
thank you oh we do have a question if
you're willing to take a question sure
probably I can't answer it but no this
just she'll give you she's she's gentle
oh I I love animals so how do I find out
if something's anim cruelty fre you is
there a logo on it yeah there the little
leaping bunny a bunny on happy bunny so
you just you just look on the back of
the product and you'll see sometimes the
bunny is missing but it will say not
tested on
animals and um and I I also like to
mention you know we just had Earth Day a
lot of these products too are
plant-based so it better for the
environment so in honor of birthday and
in and in honor of the lab day today you
know it' be great if everybody could
just buy cruelty free products it's
really easy to do is it okay that I'm
giving my cat prozac
[Laughter]
seriously yeah know I know pets are
IES
spear an answer to that question
California has the most testing of
animals but they also have the most
comprehensive laws so I hate to say it
but the laws don't seem to be stopping
it
yeah got they don't love cosmetic
testing in Cali that's about the only
one that they
don't but that's the answer to it's
California and seconded by Texas
Texas okay
thank you very much thank you thanks you
know another thing I'd like to say you
know we all say we love animals and you
know that's true it is true that if you
take any po you know most people do love
them okay got one card
left and Gina Powers
I'm reading this bill it looks like you
means the investigation of biological
processes causes of disease either under
biomedical research or um the definition
of contract testing facility I think
that they're concerned that they would
fall
under that but I can get to that in my
testimony so thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Gina powers from wrath young
and Pignatelli here today on behalf of
Dartmouth College um in opposition to
Senate Bill 97 um as amended by the
Senate um I have to issue a Maya kulpa
to the committee as I did to the prime
sponsor um admittedly we did not know
that this legislation was making its way
through the process um and we were just
notified uh a little while ago that we
might have some concerns with the
testing that we do um at our facilities
at darmouth College um we take no
position on the underlying bill um or
the underlying policy I guess I should
say but we believe um that as written it
could have some unintended
consequences um Dartmouth College is an
academic institution that receives
funding for testing through the National
Institute of Health and the National
Science Foundation and that testing that
they conduct at Dartmouth College
directly um benefit the citizens of the
State of New Hampshire um when
institutions such as Dartmouth College
receive that Federal funding it ends up
triggering a process and a requirement
that alternatives to animal testing must
be considered and the use of that
testing of animal testing needs to be
scientifically Justified and the
definition of scientifically Justified
means that Alternatives would be either
incomplete uninformative or infeasible
and that the animal model is likely to
yield important insights and that the
studies are performed with the fewest
animals possible um so unless amended um
Dartmouth has concerns that the research
um that they're doing that's
peer-reviewed um and federally funded
that's developing new cancer treatments
um treatments for cystic fibrosis and
efforts to address uh traumatic brain
injuries um PTSD and the like um could
not move forward um and so if the
committee decides that they um want to
move forward the legislation we're just
asking for um whether it be an exemption
or that the committee consider amending
one of the two definitions that I talked
about relative to either biomedical
research or contract testing facility um
to uh protect the the work that the
college is doing my understanding is
that UNH also um has some of the same
concerns that we do um but unfortunately
they were unable to be here today as
well but I do know that um Dartmouth
College and UNH um are willing to work
with any subc commmittee and provide
actual experts because believe it or not
I am not an expert in this uh in this
field um to come and discuss things with
the subcommittee should they should they
see fit um in speaking with Senator
Waters and Mr aronburg um I do
understand their concerns that any
amendment that we propose um is very
much tied to the definition of
biomedical research we're not doing any
sort of product testing um on cosme or
anything at the college so I think that
um we can definitely work with them to
ensure that um animals are protected and
that um we are doing the research within
the biomedical sphere so happy to try to
answer any questions you might
have representative MCU thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question is your concern about
translational research
primarily I would have to get back too
on that or follow up or for the question
or is it more um use of animals in like
acute or surgical intervention
training I do not believe it is training
I believe it is just strictly um within
the parameters of research for their
medical facility um they're not going to
be putting any products out to to you
know Society or anything like that I
don't think it actually has to do with
um anything that maybe darmouth
Hitchcock is doing as far as um
treatment or surgeries or surgical
interventions or anything like that if
that's what I understand your question
to be if we're having a subcommittee
that that'd be helpful to be able a
differentiate between translational TH
or clinical therapeutic or clinical
therapy or surgical intervention so we
can clarify that if it needs to be I'm
not sure it needs to be understood but
if that's your ask it' be good to know
what your well I guess I was just going
to Simply say is you have the the
language in front of you so have their
legal beagles to uh yeah oh I didn't
mean to say
that well to review it no pun intended
yeah and change change it to add or
subtract or whatever you know assume in
that sentence where the no provision of
this per you there's something they
might want to add to that sentence to
give clarification of what they they
think they might be running a foul right
and um that was the conversation that I
had with Mr aronberg and he just wanted
it to be explicit that it was for um you
know a educational Institution for the
purposes of biomedical research or
something along those lines that was
linked so you can just find something to
add to that sentence that would be great
okay thank you very
much any other questions seeing none
thank you thank you and having no more
e
hey we'll open up the public hearing and
Senate Bill 365 and hear from the prime
sponsor Senator Waters I forgot you give
my card I'll I'll hand it up to you at
the end sorry we know who you
are thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee again Senator David Waters
District Ford introduce Senate Bill
365 relative to the sale or use of
lithium ion batteries for electric
bicycles Scooters or person Electric
Mobility devices a little bit of
background on this bill um I think we've
all seen the uh great increase in
popularity of ebikes and other e
Mobility devices especially if you go to
our you know more urban areas um you'll
see great proliferation not only for
transportation but for people running
businesses delivery services and and so
forth and there's been a concern about
the safety of the batteries uh used here
um you know I saw a couple reports
around the country particularly out new
New York where there have been some some
fires that have been caused by um these
batteries so I looked into it and tried
to see what other places were doing to
make sure we ensured uh Public Safety uh
with the use of these um batteries so I
look particularly to an ordinance that
was passed in New York City and um and I
believe out uh there's been a lot of
legislation on this out in some of the
western states Utah and Nevada where um
the popular of ebikes is just soared out
out out there and and the scooters and
so forth um and uh you know it is
important for us to protect consumers
and to make sure that the products they
have are safe especially when it some
comes to something that can create a a
fire um I'm really grateful to the work
with the State Fire Marshall uh Marshall
Tumi who is here uh to work on this
language and to develop um this this
bill and uh the Fire Marshall and all
kinds of areas of fires that are
associated with the batteries and other
devices um you know a great deal of
training and trying to keep up with the
this to make sure we have the
protections that we need and so that's
what the bill is
for just as an uh I will also mention
that you know well what are we really
looking at and it it seems from the
research I could do that if you have
batteries that are appropriately tested
and labeled that the fire danger is
exceedingly low and rare but uh off
Market aftermarket Market rebuilt
counterfeit those can create some
problems I will note that there's a
recent report from Massachusetts on
there were a total of 50 fires last year
created by lithium I batteries uh none
of them were for electric bikes or
Electric Mobility devices mostly were
you know our cell phones things like
that and there was one car fire so I
said this is rare but I think we need
these Protections in place so that we
know our consumers would be appropriate
protected Ed and last thing I'll mention
is that you know technology is moving so
fast on batteries and uh there is now
commercially
available uh and I think it's going to
it's going to replace almost all the the
mobility device batteries there is a
solid state battery which cannot catch
fire and that is now being marketed by a
European country we're going to we're
going to see that eventually um become
the standard but for now I think we need
some protection so let me explain what
the bill does uh the first looking
statute I saw we did not have upto-date
definitions of batteries or of um
electric scooters or other devices so
that that that part of the first part of
the bill um is uh definitional and
updating what we had in statute which
was out outdated since we first started
to put these uh these controls in
statute um so the bill then uh addresses
two things um so uh on you'll see on H
two um that we prohibit the distribution
or selling in the state of any lithium
ion batteries or chargers for light
electric powered vehicles or personal
Mobility devices that have not been
certified by a nationally uh recognized
testing laboratory and I list the
current standards that are there for
these um and please note on lines
2122 you know working with this fire
marshal Rec you know these standards new
standards will come along uh and so it
would be under his purview to determine
if there are additional standards that
could be used in judging the safety of
the batteries since we passed in the
Senate I've been approached by a couple
of companies most particularly Nemo it's
the Outdoor Equipment company based in
Dover and they do a lot of Defense
Contracting um they're one of the main
suppliers for Department of fence and
all kinds of uh camping and other
equipment and they said that they are um
using
um lithium ion batteries and some of
their devices that are under the
European Standard so I have an uh an
amendment there which adds that European
Standard um which I think is completely
appropriate and a strict standard and
then still includes that the fire
marshall is the best judge of which
standards would be appropriate to use so
that that is what the amendment uh is
there um then uh we want to have that
that certification is visible on uh the
packaging um or on the
device um and then some exceptions uh if
people are running bikes um and so on we
can't you know ex we can't kind of go
back in time and expect that uh these
people will be uh required if it's sold
secondhand or rented I mean you know
somebody's selling a secondhand bike and
they may have scraped off that thing or
or whatever um this is for new new per
new ones um and then some violations
there which are pretty standard
violations for what I've seen other uh
municipalities and States um doing um
then the the aftermarket the second use
lithium ion batteries and this one I
think is particularly important for us
to have some regulation on um because
here's where we can't know if that
product is really safe um so that's why
uh the second the reconditioned or the
second use ones there on page two line
six are are uh covered um on line 10 uh
the the distinction is made between a
registered motor vehicle because those
are covered by other things and the
unregistered ones because we do not
require State registration of ebikes and
uh certain kinds of uh uh scooters as as
well um and then the sales provision
starting on uh with H4
um there's where we get into the uh that
it must be sealed um must be attested
and approved by and then finally
um people are pretty clever and
inventive when it comes to the getting
around the law and one thing that has be
has been noticed in New York and other
places that people are creating
counterfeit
stickers and so we need to have in
statute that if you create a counterfeit
sticker um you broken the law um so
consumer protection and I think this
puts us in a good place to make sure as
these devices become more popular that
we have in statute what we need and I
and I you know the expert really on on
all this is our our fire marshal and um
I'm I really appreciate his help with
this and he's here to answer some of the
questions about what what they're seeing
in in the in the fire departments in the
fire service so thank you Mr chairman
okay representative baros thanks for
taking a question I don't know if I
should ask you or or um the fire chief
um I was contacted by the um uh um
National Bike group and they suggested
um in terms of the standard that it
should say on it's line 19 that um
instead of nationally recognized Testing
Lab laboratory that it' be ISO
accredited so I don't know you know if
it that that was one suggestion and you
mentioned the European Standard and they
delineated that as being
en15194 so I thought I'd bring that up
as well thank you for that I'd heard
from them too and I I will leave it to
um Marshall Tumi on this um I I do think
that last phrase as approved by the New
Hampshire State Fire Marshall that that
is quite comprehensive okay but if the
Marshall thinks that it would be
appropriate to mention that standard
which I know the bike folks are have
suggested of course it makes sense yeah
yeah thank you thank you very much thank
you Mr chairman and I I have to dash for
another bill but if there are any
questions that anything I can do please
let me know thank you okay the official
record
card okay uh Sean Tumi
um are you are you are you are official
fire fire marshall or director of The
Office good afternoon Sean to me I'm the
State Fire Marshall thank you for the
opportunity to speak to this afternoon I
think Senator Waters um laid things out
pretty well um I don't leave doesn't
leave a lot we I did have the
opportunity to work with them in uh
reviewing this bill we crafted it on a
lot of the um language and work that New
York has been doing because they've been
seeing and researching most of the
issues around e-mobility um fires and
ebike fires um I think the biggest thing
in in our our mind is that as Senator
Waters indicated the
um the ones that are are certified
products tend to have less issues and in
uh 2022 the consumer product safety
commission uh really pushed on
manufacturers and resellers and others
to try to move towards uh certifications
and then in November of 23 there was a
national uh campaign that identified six
areas that uh revolved around battery
safety and the first one is uh choosing
certified products so there's a real
emphasis over the last couple years that
we're certified products we're going to
have uh less issues around fire fires I
will say that capturing the data
nationally is a bit of a challenge our
National Data um system for U fires is
um a little bit in the past and it's
going under a significant rework with
the US fire Administration right now uh
we have been finding we've we've asked
Fire Chiefs in in New Hampshire to start
collecting it and giving us information
we're fortunately only seeing about 8 to
10 fires a year over the last couple
years around these types of devices but
as the pop ity of increases we want to
make sure we get ahead of some of the
challenges and really try to I think set
up for Success um that we have the right
devices good education and things like
that so I think uh you know putting this
language in the bill and asking our
consumers when they purchase new uh
devices to buy certified use certified I
think would be a great step for fire
safety for our citizens in the state um
and I'd ask for you to support the bill
any questions great questions
oh over here representative
selling thank you and thank you for what
you do so my question is around uh two
two parts the the enforcement part is
number one and the consumer education is
another part so I'm not sure if that's
included in this bill sure I think the
the way the framework of the enforcement
could be left left to any real law
enforcement um official it's open for
the fines and um the structure is pretty
open as far as far as uh any law
enforcement uh agency could enforce the
fines if so if they needed to um as far
as the education goes we've been doing a
lot of education on social media
outreach in our office over the last um
probably two years um and we'll
occasionally do uh informational um
bulletins on uh lithium ion battery
safety we've been doing a lot for the
fire service around suppression efforts
um working with the fire academy to do
more and more around training for the
fire fire service service um any of the
the events that we go to we try to have
a component to lithium B battery safety
as well there's a a bill also in um
that's on the uh believe it's coming up
on the consent calendar that talks about
electric vehicle and lithium B battery
um doing a a study um council is what
it's going to end up being and it's
asked uh my office to be the meedi to be
the chair of it but to bring a bunch of
the stakeholders across the state to
really look at lithium a bigger picture
lithium batteries and electric vehicles
and try to help get education and stuff
out so I think we're just I think we've
we've got a lot more to do in the area
but I think uh anything we can do to
kind of get ahead and and educate the
consumers will be good so especially at
yeah representative M thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question and thanks for doing what you
do um any input on the definition of
electric scooter was that taken from
some other standard definition and yeah
do that impact the the scooter the Lang
these definitions came uh mostly from
the language that New York are craft and
and stuff the work they did over the
last year or two there so trying to
merror as closely as what the guidance
is that other areas in the country have
done so it's try to trying to be
consistent I think you know to the point
about the I think the iso and some of
that other language this is constantly
evolving and it's moving pretty fast so
I think um having a little bit of
flexibility for me to like yeah that
that nationally restur
nationally recognized Testing Lab is is
good or you know uh that fits the mold
of what we're after I think is is a good
thing um you know I think we we might
have to come back to you in in a year or
two and make some other minor changes I
think because it's just things are are
moving a little bit faster than the
codes and standards around this in this
area
repres thank you thank you for taking
our questions um I just had a question
about uh data around the fires that have
been happening I've been reading about
them uh is there data to support that
those fires were caused by
uncertified uh batteries and
manufacturers is that supported by the
data we thank you I we don't have I
don't say we don't have that to that
level in New Hampshire um how about
nationally nationally uh I'd have to do
a little B more research honestly on
that right now and just follow for the
question mqu I just want to focus in on
the word recondition online
six um what H So currently are batteries
being reconditioned and repurposed and
uh where do the batteries go if they
can't be reconditioned do they go to the
landfill or do they go to you know does
this pre prevent recycling if we prevent
reconditioning there is um thank you
there are opportunities and there's some
uh companies out there that do battery
recycling at this point um and so that
that's available actually the in the
initiative that I talked about there is
uh a point about proper disposal as well
um and there's a bill that was
introduced this session that talks about
proper disposal in New Hampshire as far
landfills represent post thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here today
um is that um would that be hazardous
waste I believe that's where they put it
into yeah yeah it's
I I do know in New Hampshire there are
towns that no longer have uh the ability
to um store hazardous waste where they
are because
um some conglomerate of uh towns had
gotten together and then they disbanded
so um we do have towns that are left
without it so what what would we do with
in that case I would have to research
that call
me I'll store him at my house no
thank
you
yeah all right thank you very much thank
hearing okay put fire Marsh's phone
number on the I I I put it in my phone
it's there like because because I used
to remember the old guy was our Fire
Marshall for years I didn't even know we
today good afternoon chairman hunt
members of the Commerce Committee always
a pleasure to be back before you my name
is Grant bossy I'm Deputy Chief of Staff
of the New Hampshire Senate here to
introduce uh Senate Bill 334 on behalf
of Senator Dan Enis the Bill's Prime
sponsor uh currently student loan
programs uh public at least State
student loan programs in New Hampshire
are bonded through the New Hampshire
higher educ ation assistance foundation
and the New Hampshire health and
education facilities Authority or hea
this bill would simply empower the New
Hampshire business Finance Authority to
also issue bonds for these student loans
um this is a way they could issue them
without fees would provide another path
potentially for a more affordable way
for students to uh Finance their higher
education uh I will defer technical
questions to the EXP s behind me uh who
are testifying in support of this bill
but if you have any questions for
Senator inis I can be sure to get you an
answer thank you for your consideration
and support of Senate Bill
334 perfect thank you very
much okay James
BFA yeah you got to press the button
good afternoon Mr chairman thank you for
having me today uh for the record I'm
James key Wallace executive director of
the New Hampshire business Finance
Authority just here to make a couple
very quick points I think I said three
minutes on my card I'll try to stick to
it um and I'm happy to take any
questions that that you'd like um Mr
bossy summarized it well this simply
adds the BFA to the allowed issuers of
bonds that support lowcost student loans
for kids going to school in New
Hampshire from New Hampshire their
families things like that um this comes
at no cost to the taxpayer um this is
not a taxpayer supportive program
there's no fees paid out of the budget
or any other sense uh for this these
bonds are actually private loans from
the capital markets going to private
families but there's a state agency in
that process who authorizes the What's
called the issuance of the bond and kind
of looks it over and makes sure that
everything's compliant with regulations
there are limits to how much a state can
issue in these type of bonds each year
um these are not like the bonds that the
state issues for like Capital planning
these are not State debts um and that
limit is what's known as volume cap the
BFA is the agency that receives that
volume cap and the way it works now is
when a student loan provider needs to go
to the market and get the capital to
make those loans they have to come to
the BFA apply to get the volume cap it
has to get transferred over to New
Hampshire hea the New Hampshire hea
issues the bonds and this just sort of
allows them if they choose to cut out
some of those intermediate steps it cuts
costs it makes the loans more affordable
for the families in New Hampshire um and
it's just a more efficient kind of minor
tweak to the process and I'm happy to
Sullivan uh thank you for taking my
question so I'm just kind of curious
about the structure of all of this so if
if these bonds go bad or taxpayers on
the hook no definitely not definitely
not so if if so who who is on the hook
then if if somebody stops paying them
back the lender yeah these are just
normal loans student loans that lenders
make to
families okay so when the state's
issuing or taking out bonds or issuing
Bonds on their behalf if that lender
can't pay back to state for those bonds
or am I misunderstanding how this all
worse yeah it's a good question it's I
wish they were called something other
than bonds because there's really I mean
the word bond can mean so many things
right there's there's the type of bonds
that New Hampshire issues to borrow
money for right and they borrow money
and they spend it on all sorts of things
there's another type of bond which are
known as conduit bonds and that's the
type of bond that we're talking about
it's the type of bond the BFA issues
hundreds of millions you know on regular
course what a conduit bond is is it goes
through a state agency because an agency
by law has to say that the use of these
proceeds is what's known as qualified
for its purpose so student loans for
student loans bonds docks and Wares and
airports for those kind of bonds but
it's called a conduit Bond because the
bond documents themselves say in no way
remotely ever is the issuer or the state
responsible for the repayment of these
bonds it's purely playing an
administrative role to say do these
bonds fit into the federal category that
allows the bonds to be issued in the
first place um those are called conduit
bonds um they're very very common
they're used all the time to finance all
sorts of different projects um their
private Market
transactions um just as they are in this
case all right cool thank you yep
sure okay representative taxton so 45
years ago the Commonwealth of Virginia
had something called the Virginia
educational Loan Authority they issued
conduit barns my education is as a
result of those
bonds at that time the private interest
or the interest rates on the Pu on the
private market for typically for a house
were around
15% maybe 13 depends upon the year and
uh my student loans were at 7 and a
half% which was a grand deal in my son's
experience who's roughly 40 years
younger than me his he borrowed money to
go to college in what was effectively a
4 and a half% market and the interest
rates on the private loans that he got
were at
9% or 8ish or whatever so there's a
difference in the arrangement and the
when I borrowed the money and paid it
off
um the there was a you could refinance
so is the the two questions that I have
regarding these potential loans this
potential conduit for funding education
are are you likely to be loaning the
money to New Hampshire students and
families at or below current market
rates or at or above Cur current market
rates and do they is there a function in
this Bond structure where would it would
allow uh student borrowers because one
of the big controversies in the public
obviously today is student borrowing and
it would help a significant number of
borrowers who don't have uh uh who have
student loans that would be able to
refinance them at
more Equitable rates than some of these
kids borrowed money at 11 and a half
percent so my that's my question is
there a refinance option in here does
this provide for that which would go a
long way to reduce pressure on student
borrowers and or is it new money
only and uh the question is where where
do you expect this to settle for
interest rates is this going to be a
premium rate because it's a sub subprime
product or is this going to be a
preferential rate because it's a good
thing to do sure thank you
representative um so just to make sure
it's 100% clear so the BFA is not
lending any of this money to anyone
we're just performing the function we're
issuing the bond the New Hampshire
higher education you know loan
corporation they're the ones who are the
student lenders and and deal with all of
that in in general and I don't know if
they're here today actually but um in
general so the way that it works is
these bonds are what are known as tax
exempt bonds um which means that when
they're then offered to the ultimate
borrower they're typically about
25% lower of an interest rate than what
the typical Market would be because the
the entity buying the bond sort of
providing the big bulk of capital which
then gets lent out you know they don't
have to pay taxes on the money they earn
from that bond in exchange by lowering
the rate by that same amount and
depending on their tax bracket as an
institutions typically about
25% which sort of lines up with what I
heard your student loans were close
anyhow um you know I I I can't speak to
I think you said it was your your son's
situation but these are yeah yeah so
these would be tax exempt bonds for New
Hampshire students who generally are
getting a better deal than they would
get in the market because of their Nexus
to New
Hampshire um and I I I don't know the
answer to your refinance question I
melier quick question who's the end
owner
Bond insti or is it typically
a these
bonds it depends so there are a couple
ways to sell Bonds on the market and you
know the way that you do it would
ultimately be up to that higher
education loan corporation or New
Hampshire Advantage I think it's called
now um generally speaking it depends on
the size so if the bond is big enough
like let's say it's 20 million or 5050
million for example they would do what's
called a public offering where they go
to the capital markets and you get like
the bank of americaas and US Banks to
bid on the bonds and whoever gives the
lowest interest rate in the private
Market buys the bonds um often times
bonds are available for you know if
you're on like your Fidelity account or
whatever and you can see it um you could
go buy Bond if they're rated for
individual purchase um it depends on the
on the bond by Bond just a quick follow
what do you expect the rating on these
bonds to
be that's a great question I I'd have to
defer that to the New Hampshire
Advantage folks the um student loan
corporation it depends on how they
package them I wish they were here
actually yeah I assume other states have
done this typically what have been the
ratings do you know are you aware of
that I I'm not aware I this was just
done last year I could probably go look
it up and come back to you in a few
minutes but um these are kind of a very
normal thing that happen all the time in
the market thank you very much sure okay
now representa Barz thanks for taking my
question um and uh chairman hunt
instituted a new thing in this committee
called Story Hour so I'm going to follow
along with that so if if Little Johnny
hunt wants to get um wants to get a
student loan where go to college finally
go to college right where would um where
would how would he get how would he get
access to this money for a student loan
through the New Hampshire higher
education loan corporation which is a
nonprofit organiz you app directly yeah
you would apply to them maybe it goes
through the financial aid office at
school used to have another
name yeah was it was granite or
something like that it was something was
in Hampshire Granite State Management
and Resources I think they they have a
they had another I never was a name
another name for it but back when my
kids were in college yes I I actually I
think I borrowed money from them same in
the 90s yeah and remember the stone
their logo the stone logo yeah I saw it
every month I think but um yeah as
someone who does buy bonds um your the
bond market is usually is bundled
they're usually bundled in several other
Bond issues and um and it's it's
basically uh terms of your portfolio you
want to have a balanced portfolio
they're all definitely a a-rated bonds
and there's not you know um but um there
it is obviously for people who are
interested in in investing in the bond
market and and normally it's only
someone who has enough that you want to
spread around that you you want to have
the bond market is is a safety net um
you other most people are in the stock
market you're not necessarily in the
bond market
so okay representing you're next oh I
was po
outt oh I can't forget representative
question thank you very much um and
thank you for being here today uh so for
um story I had a son that went to school
and um for a a grad school
and he couldn't get any loans other than
private loans and the only way he could
get any forgiveness while other people
took you know loans um that you know
weren't private um a lot of these people
got um their money paid back and now he
is stuck
with huge nut however with this
program they they have have if you work
for a nonprofit for 10 years you get
they they pay they pay the rest of the
loan off what's left is that what will
happen with this program since this is
private even though it's put through the
New
Hampshire
um whatever it was called Advantage uh
yes representative thank you great
question I wish I knew the answer with
confidence um you know really because
because the state's not the lender you
know we we try not to get too entangled
in the ins and outs of the actual loans
to the students that's really for them
to do but um you know I I think the
federal student loan forgiveness program
as far as I'm aware is for federal
student loans only and if I recall the
New Hampshire Advantage group used to be
a servicer of Federal loans I don't
believe that they are any more right I'm
seeing some shaking heads back there so
I think these are a separate thing um I
yeah this is a private nonprofit um
doing loans for people in New Hampshire
yeah just just your information your
representative
post rep representative post have your
son refinance his loans through a
federal agency and they have the new
program that the government just had I
can't remember what it's called but if
you refinance them through that they
will do it and it'll become a Federal
tell okay now representa am has a
question thank you thank you for taking
my question um just to just to play off
some of the previous questions let's say
I'm me and a whole bunch of my young
friends took out loans through this Bond
and other people are getting their loans
paid off but we're not so we say we're
not going to pay our loans either and we
all do it at the same time time and the
bond goes uh you know in default whose
credit rating is at risk I know I
understand the borrower but is is the
state agency or the state itself is
their credit rating at risk thank you
represent representative uh the state or
any agency is most certainly not at risk
we're not guaranteeing the bond or
correct putting our name on it or well I
mean our name is there as issuer but
we're not putting our credit behind it
the entity that would be at risk would
be the New Hampshire higher education
loan Corporation they're they're the
obligor they're the ones who are
borrowing the money to then go lend it
and if they can't pay their bond back I
mean it's a lot of people's problem but
it's not the state's problem just a
quick followup does it affect your
ability to to uh issue the next Bond
whatever that may be for does it affect
your ability to to do that uh thank you
it does not affect the BFA or the
state's ability to issue bonds um for
any other project it might affect that
loan corporations ability to borrow debt
in the future abut if they default um
but that's that's pretty understandable
yeah okay ra representative raor thank
you thanks for taking my question um how
much money do you expect to float each
year in bonds and would you expect it to
be an ongoing yearly
event that's a great question
representative um I believe there were 0
do in bonds issued for the the last
several years um there was I think 20 or
30 million in total issued in the most
recent 12 months um the first time in
quite a long time and it actually has to
do with the interest rate uh dynamics
that representative uh taxton um
introduced before so that difference
between the regular bond rate and the
tax exempt rate is 25% right reduction
that's only meaningful enough if rates
are high enough to make the discount
sort of worth it in the market versus
you know kind of transaction fees and
things like that um so this was uh the
first time in quite some time the
student loan corporation tells me they
expect the interest rate environment to
be such that they'll be kind of in the
market looking for bonds for the next
couple years outside of that it's it
becomes difficult to predict yeah
followup for question me inquire um
there's been a lot of issues with
student loan servicers over the years
who'll be servicing these
loans they I believe service their own
loans um in- house um and I'm not a
regulatory body but Dr Google they have
a pretty high
you okay thank you very much thanks
thank you I have no more cards so we
will close close the public hearing and
spill
[Music]
brownie
e
bill of the day Senate Bill 35 uh Senate
Bill 515 relative to Consumer guaranteed
contracts and we have a stand in
here
okay do it
daily
rette good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chairman good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Daley Fett and I'm the Senate majority
caucus director I was asked to introduce
this bill on behalf of Senator Lang
sb515 would make modifications and
updates to Consumer guarantee contracts
and is a request of the insurance
department the insurance department
testified in the Senate that there has
been an influx of unbranded mailers and
the department has received quite a few
complaints regarding this issue so this
bill will help tighten up the state law
so that unbranded mailers would need to
identify
themselves I'm going to keep it very
brief today since it's a insurance
department request I would uh defer any
questions to them thank you very much
perfect good job very very brief for you
we don't want a story from you okay uh
so are you guys gonna do tag team yeah
you last this committee long enough
employee James has been around a long
time I haven't been around 12 years and
I've been in coming here for 20 years my
previous job um my name is James Fox I'm
the PNC director at the New Hampshire
insurance department I'm joined by Josh
hilard who's our uh enforcement counsel
at the department uh this bill kind of
impacts both what I do which is PNC and
what Josh does with his enforcement um
the the statute we're addressing is a
415c which is consumer guarantee
contracts which have uh kind of a unique
distinction at the department that
they're not Insurance U but they're
similar enough to insurance that they're
regulated by the department what they um
what they are basically is if you buy a
car and they said you would do like an
extended warranty that's a consumer
guarantee contract if you go to a store
and buy pretty much anything that's
going to they'll offer you an extended
uh
warranty um the reason we're um
modernizing or increasing regulation on
the bill is that we've had basically um
the good actors in this area um the gray
area actors and then the Bad actors um
we're not worried about the good actors
uh but the the gray area and the Bad
actors uh have become a concern uh of
recent times there seem to be more
people out there um issuing these
contracts have not registered with the
Department um we're not able to um
properly basically regulate them because
we're not sure who they are
so um who gets hurt by that uh is the
most vulnerable people in our population
a lot of times it's seniors um Josh will
get into that a a little later but they
receive phone calls from companies that
not really 415c contracts and they can
for example give out their um banking
information and then they've compromised
their Banking and then once they do that
then they can get uh many many phone
calls in a day every day uh and it
becomes both a problem for the senior
and for the senior's families um we
partnered with uh a P um on addressing
these issues and what we've basically
done is taken 415c which is the consumer
guarantee contracts and made a few uh
changes to it um the first change is
we've um strengthened identification uh
in it so we know who the obligor are
which that would be like the insurance
company if for insurance and then who
the administrators and the sellers are
so we know each layer of person that's
going to be interacting um with
consumers and that way whatever we get
information wise we can trace it back to
the oore and then contact the obligor
and have them U make the necessary
changes to whatever their behavior is
and we'd also then also be able to find
out that the entity we're dealing with
is not registered with us and they then
we take a different tact and try to stop
them from um operating in the state at
all um next thing that we did much like
insurance if everybody doesn't know we
receive most almost all insurance forms
and we review most of them review 415c
contracts so now the um 415c companies
will be submitting their forms to us for
us to review um to make sure that they
they meet the standards of
415c and then the last piece um
that's it looks a little the actual Bild
looks longer but a lot of it was
actually just reorganization um the last
piece is we have more prohibited acts
and in particular we're not going to
allow unbranded solicitations so if
you've ever gotten a mailer uh saying
you know your your vehicle uh is in
trouble because it's not been uh you
don't you're ability coverage or is your
coverage for your car is running out you
must contact the company and then they
don't say who they are um whatever car
you have right in the past I always get
I love that when they send it for my SS
right and I'm chairman hun I'm sure when
you get it you throw it in the trash but
you know a lot of seniors go oh my God
is this the registration for my car I
better call I could am I in trouble um
so that so unbranded those are not
allowed so now we can say public service
announcements if you see receive an
unbranded flyer that is illegal and you
should everybody should throw it in the
trash very simply um we also are not
going to allow the high pressure tactics
which is the you know you must respond
with this many days um you're at risk
your car is at risk um you could be
liable for thousands of dollars th those
are all going to be illegal and anything
um that's targeted at seniors in
particular uh is also going to be um IL
illegal if this passes and get signed uh
so we we spent and I I want to emphasize
that we spend a lot of time uh working
with with the the good actors uh and
their and their industry Representatives
uh and they've been uh very helpful and
they have a a a similar concern because
they don't want the uh a bad name for
their industry so uh there are a lot of
good actors out there they did help us
with the bill um we went back and forth
and we think we've developed a bill that
will increase protections for the
consumers um basically from us being
able to regulate better to know who
we're regulating and and and basically
be able to stop them like pressure
Flyers weren't illegal prior to this um
but I will also I will now hand it over
to Josh to explain a little bit more
from the enforcement perspective uh both
prior to the the bill and what the bill
would be like after the
bill sure thank you James so as part of
the enforcement division um I have the
honor of trying to look into any of
these complaints that come into the
department and we've received many many
complaints dozens of complaints from
consumers both those who have purchased
these products and those who have not
purchased but who continue to receive
mailers or calls um that they find
harassing but one of the difficulties we
often times have is identifying who
exactly is behind it because there's no
name on these mailers um myself and my
team has spent countless hours trying to
track down some of these entities
calling these numbers where um you know
it's been actually very difficult that
we've had some of these companies very
abusive towards myself and some of the
people I work with when we try to track
down who these people are and make it
known to them that you know we regulate
you in the state you're a consumer
guarantee contract provider or seller
and we need to know more about you know
who is the obligor backing this who are
you selling this who are you selling to
um and it's been quite difficult without
um any sort of structure in terms of
what's required on these mailers so in
my eyes this is one of the most
important changes though the others that
James mentioned are also you know very
important in terms of changes of
tightening up this market and like he
said um really going after the Bad
actors in this market while still
providing plenty of space for many of
those good actors who work in this in
this market to to service New Hampshire
consumers happy to take any
questions you do any solvency tests do
we get
financials the companies are required to
post a bond but other than that there's
no solvency tests okay because that's
the whole reason it was given to the
insurance department in the first place
these guaranteed contracts is because
that's your expertise but okay so they
do have to post a bond yes okay
cool are these extended warranties this
what you're talking about when they at
the point of sale they try to have you
sign something you want an extended
guarantee correct often times they're
called extending warranties or service
contracts and they're on things such as
you know automobiles sometimes you get
mail about home warranties or a
different sorts of consumer products as
well um Walmart does this for just about
everything you buy there except for food
if you plug it in Walmart does it do and
just be clear it's not only at the point
of say
you're probably not as worried about the
point of sale when it's the cold calls
and mailings that are probably much more
of the problem
okay okay representative
taxon uh what about phone solicitations
since I've been here this morning I've
had at least four calls come through on
my cell phone where they're soliciting
uh you know warranties or your car
the the whatever the gasket on your your
your warranty on your car that you sold
three years ago is expired and I mean
it's absurd and I don't even know where
they get these I don't where they get I
don't really understand where they get
my number or what vehicle I own and
so you know if you pick the phone up
there's a long pause this is where you
know the over 70 the older people here
uh they you you get these phone calls
and there's a gurgling and a banging
sound and then you wind up with a that's
when I hang up in a phone room and it's
somebody who may not have the best
understanding of the English language
and they're trying to sell you a
warranty or something is that covered
under this bill or is it just mailings
no no that that would be also that would
be saying that would be an illegal
extended warranty that that would be
prohibited
um let alone it violates the Do Not Call
if you're listed and do not call if you
have never done business with them
before yeah right
okay rent M uh thank you chairman H um
is there such thing as an actual
legitimate car warranty if you if you
listen to their advertisements they say
buy this coverage and you'll be covered
for all the repairs covered
repairs nothing is covered that's my
covered well that's why we're we we're
going to have form review too that they
have to submit the forms for our review
it's a long-standing rule in Insurance
you can't give out aery coverage so if
it was an elusory coverage in 415c uh we
would also uh be able to block that um
but again as I said there are there are
good actors uh in uh the market uh and
then there's there a gray area and then
there's the Absolut bad scam people who
aren't registered and aren you're just
basically trying to get your money um
and we're trying to sort everybody out
and make sure we can identify everybody
and then after this is in place for a
few years we'll have a better
understanding of uh who exactly
everybody is so this is to a certain
extent maybe a step one I mean if if we
find uh we're able to block the Bad
actors and we don't need to do anything
any further then we would be done but if
if this um you know in the next few
years and you know Insurance always
takes a little time to catch up we
determine that um more needs to be done
then uh we'll be back yeah
and I should add the department has been
taking action against the Bad actors we
have been able to identify and has both
taken administrative action through the
hearings process as well as entered into
consent orders with a number of these
entities where number of them either
left the state or agreed to terms to
comply with um the current state law as
it is or face you know further Financial
penalties represent Grassi none of this
would cover offshore companies that are
doing the scammers people that are not
in the United States oh that's
no if if they were if they're um acting
if they're calling you in the United
States or or contacting or FL sending
you a mailer in the United States then
that they need to be registered here
there like any insurance company that's
acting in the United States now you know
those entities may not care I mean this
they they're just going to do what they
do um but that's why we want to try to
organize what uh would constitute uh a
good uh company for example um no
unbranded um mailers and no high
pressure tactic and then we can more
confidently go to the public in New
Hampshire and that's one of the things
we're doing with the ARP and and try to
make it clear that if you receive
something um like you know an unbranded
mail or or or if you receive a cold call
that um is not tied you should you
should tell them to put it in the mail
to you and you'll review it but don't
buy anything over the phone I mean that
would be rule number one we could
already do that and we have done that um
with AARP and different presentations um
uh but it's harder to get the the
mailers now because they weren't illegal
mailers they were just um unwise to
respond to now they'll be
illegal is it male
fraud uh that's not our jurisdiction it
could be I'm not sure mean for the under
the postal I don't know yeah could be
okay uh represent thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking our questions I I'm
just confused by one couple lines in the
bill and maybe you can explain it page
25 the consumer does not have the so uh
no no consumer guarantee contract shall
provide that the consumer does not have
the right to bring an action to enforce
the terms of the contract or otherwise
challenged enough like page three line
25 so letter C there yeah Roman numer
four just if you just explain like why
that is needed in the bill I just don't
contract yeah you you got to go back to
what the ran numeral right I understand
it's a you can't it's a Prohibition
against no o a contract that says you
can't enforce the contract I I didn't
know that was a Poss possible thing you
could put in a contract well that that's
one of the concerns that that these
contracts have things in them that you
would think wouldn't be there but are
there I mean I had I had one contract
where I read and it said we we uh uh we
provide coverage for uh
um I was it was uh scratches and
dentless repair of dings or some repair
some minor repair and then the exclusion
had exactly what the coverage was so
you'd be I know you I know it sounds
like why would you need to put that why
why would you have something that says
you can't say the consumer is not a part
of the contract but that's what the
contracts are they're assuming the
person doesn't read it right and then um
but is that legally enforceable probably
not but you know that again so if if
you're
if you sending it to an unsophisticated
person uh and then they some people may
just think they're out of luck um so
that's why we again we want to get so
our our intent is to get the forms and
then what we do is we we're going to do
a kind of an audit of the forms we'll
pull so many of them and kind of just
keep reviewing them on a rotating basis
and we catch things uh that shouldn't be
in there because they're literally
listed here shouldn't be in there or
anything we think is uh deceptive will
have it uh
removed thank
you um so if we're going to set a
General rule of
thumb that a contract an extended
warranty contract that is sold in the
retail environment you just purchase I.E
Walmart that one is probably going to be
okay that contract is you know they
probably or Staples always wants to sell
when you you buy something but it's
anything that is done through
mail email text or phone call and I know
I know Josh wants to say one thing but I
want say what I would say um that the
larger the uh retailer probably the
closer you ought to be uh being um in a
good position but the smaller the
retailer I think sometimes they get
contacted and they they're um saying
well you know we if you sell these you
know almost like we will sell these for
you uh we'll do a mailer put your name
at the top uh and uh and then that re
that that retailer doesn't have a lot of
knowledge about what's going on they
they are getting a kind of a commission
so I would say the larger so there are
examples of like Amazon is is a classic
they do a lot of that and Walmart does
and so you know my you know somewhat
unsophisticated opinion is that the
smaller the entity more likely they
might just be partnering with someone
who said that you know this is a
something that can be sold in a kind as
as an adjacent item to what you're
selling and it has value and we we'll
we'll let you have some of that value
but I'll let Josh
one of the things I would add chairman
Hunt is that when it's at a point of
sale like that the consumer knows where
to go when there's a concern they can
reach out to the Walmart or the Staples
and if they call us they can say I
purchased this from Walmart or Staples
the big issue we've been facing is when
consumers have purchased these products
sort of sight unseen they receive a
mailer that has no branding they receive
a call and they provide their
information and that sale goes through
and then they come to us and say I
bought this service contract and I'm not
getting any of the benefits and then
it's a real hurdle for us to even
identify who we need to be taking action
against in order to to make sure they're
complying with the terms of the contract
for the consumer
great yes representative grassing yeah
to follow up on on representative am's
amon's question if you look at line 21
it says those Provisions are not allowed
in any contracts yeah I totally
understood that yeah okay I I was just
curious why we would have to Pro
prohibit it prohibit what is obviously
nonsense right and I would just like to
one thing you know you know we're saying
that you know we have people who come
and say they didn't receive anything but
there's also uh we have had some
relatives call and say that I was
checking uh my mother or my father's
bank account and there's a charge on
there and it looks like it's uh says
Auto protection uh and uh can you look
into that for us is that insurance and
it's and it's um one of these bad actor
companies and we say well did your
parent receive anything in the mail no
um basically they they they gave they
bought something over the phone never
received a contract and all they end
ended up getting was a charge um on
their on their checking account
yeah
landline over 70 no landline for you and
be and you know I know but we have had
people who have had to change their
phone number because because of the
situation yeah no I can see that for
sure great thank you very much thank you
okay I have one card here uh Travis
Moore who comes comes all the way from
Kansas City
bill all right good afternoon chairman
hunt and members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to testify in
front of you this afternoon my name is
Travis Moore and I general counsel for
the service Contra service contract
indust Street Council we're a national
trade Association that represents the
nation's leading service contract
providers and administrators and of
course as you've just heard service
contracts means extended warranties home
warranty really any type of product that
would protect your financial interests
and everything from a cell phone to a
motor vehicle to your household systems
and appliances um as you've heard today
I would like to think that I'm here
today representing those good guys in
this space these are valuable products
that a lot of consumers depend on to
protect their finances most the average
American Consumer cannot afford a $400
or more unexpected expense and that's
happens all the time from normal wear
and tear and breakdown from your vehicle
to your appliances or your HVAC system
in your home whatever the case might be
and these products help those consumers
cover those expenses and so there are
really valuable products that our
members offer and we want them to be
available to consumers in New Hampshire
and we want to support the good actors
that are offering those products and
doing it the right way that goes from
servicing claims all the way to
marketing and that's why I'm here today
to encourage you to support this bill uh
I want to thank the Department of
Insurance who has been very good about
working with us and reaching out early
on to make sure that we understand what
this bill does and how we can help the
insurance department to address concerns
within the industry that Frank
uh damage the reputation of the industry
I've already heard it from some of you I
know that there are Bad actors out there
and there's bad conduct and frankly that
makes my job a heck of a lot harder and
it's not good for my member companies so
for that for those reasons we really do
support this legislation and we would
encourage you to uh to uh vote a pass
and with that I'll happy to be a
punching bag if you've had a bad
experience with service contracts and
take any questions that you might have
right but the the point being is that uh
you you want to sell these things you
want to keep business so you want get
rid of the bad actor so we won't be so
gun-shy when these products are offered
to us yes absolutely so I have good and
bad stories
so my best story is when Volvo sold me a
a a warranty on my tires of my car my
Volvo v90 which you might know is a very
a very limited edition that Volvo sold
and they sold it with pelli tires and I
go I don't know about pelli they really
have a bad reput and he says okay well
we'll sell you this for $1,200 we'll
sell you g a warranty on those on those
wheels and sure enough it didn't take me
more than three months before I start
those plli started popping on me and so
that was absolutely worthwhile that
warranty that I got
absolutely and got Michelin instead all
I did want to also chairman hunt address
you mentioned earlier Financial
Assurance Provisions which are an
important part of of how these products
get offered and I did want to stress
that the current consumer guaranteed
contract law does have Financial
Assurance Provisions in it they're
relatively consistent with the niic
model approach to regulating these
products and so while there's a bond
it's actually um there are actually
three different options for how uh
companies comply with the financial
Assurance it's not just a bond if you
opt for the bond you have also have to
maintain a funded Reserve account that's
40% of any of the premiums received for
these contracts and if you don't do that
then you would have to maintain a
contract liability insurance policy that
backs these products so if anything
happens that insurance policy actually
makes sure the clim is paid so there are
um uh it's an insurance product behind
the insurance this is kind of like
reinsurance kind of like
reinsurance great yeah
so all right thank you very much thank
you very much and I have no more
cards so we are
done
okay I don't see
see we're waiting for an
up on
long
e
okay all right so what we're going to do
this is we're going to open up the
subcommittee on Senate Bill
407 and I am here pcel is here
representing 's here and representative
spear is sending in for representative
Gibbs and representative burough is
here okay so uh Alex you want to take
please and uh tell us tell us what we
have in front of us okay I just realized
I was probably going to be asked to do
that well we hav't ask you to tell the
story yet but yeah once upon a time
there was a uh an
amendment um this amendment
um has three parts um and and uh the
first thing I'd like to mention it has
now become a session law because
basically it is a um directive to carry
out a project that will be finished
within the year um and um at the advice
of legislative Services I agreed that it
you know should be written up as a
session law um and it has
um I think three main
components um the first is the cost
reporting requirement so there's
requirement on am ground ambulance
providers in the state to submit cost
reports um the cost report will be
designed by the Actuarial and accounting
expert that gets retained to receive the
reports but that expert is encouraged to
use the Medicare cost reporting template
that already exists and that people are
familiar with um and which I understand
is no small task to
complete um so and the um Commissioner
of safety has the enforcement authority
to set a deadline for the submission of
those cost
reports um which deadline will be worked
out in
consultation with the insurance
commissioner who's responsible for
making sure that this project moves
along at a pace sufficient to be
completed by the end of the
year um so after the cost reporting um
there's a process set up for the
retention of a Actuarial accounting
expert um which will go through the New
Hampshire Health Plan uh which is
um a quasi governmental entity that's
supervised by the insurance commissioner
and that performs specific government
functions around health insurance
markets um so that entity has the
authority to
assess Health carriers uh to perform
these functions and that assessment is
the funding mechanism uh that will pay
for the cost of the study
so step two then is the assessment and
the retention of the Actuarial and
accounting expert um and
then
um step three is the collection of the
information um and the putting together
of a report which will summarize the
cost information and which will also um
require the this firm
to establish um what did I call it an
illustrative uh fee schedule so what
would a fee schedule look like Statewide
fee schedule look like that actually um
paid based on
cost um the cost based reimbursement
system so
um so the third step is actually just
sort of the
work of collecting the information and
putting together a
report um which includes um description
of costs this illustrative fee
schedule um and an Actuarial estimation
of what the uh Prem the impact would be
on health insurance premiums of a cost
based reimbursement
model
um and um if you want to add a four step
who would just be the submission of
information okay um I guess that I I
want to uh accentuate or emphasize is um
if starting at line 12 what we're you
know beginning the effective date um and
the process providing this of
Contracting
within conducting the study the costs
incurred in the revenue collected by the
ground ambulance providers related to
the provisions of ground ambulance
services in the state
including the cost of sustaining a
reasonable operating margin in support
of the expectation that the ground
ambulance providers in the state
maintain
Readiness to meet demand for the
services so it's not about just being
fee for service here we're talking about
you have we are going to consider the
cost of the
equipment and be having the uh the
proper equipment and Personnel to
provide the services that we were we all
hope to get from our ambulances yes
during the summit meetings we heard loud
and clear that part of operating cost is
this more intangible cost of
Readiness and this this is uh directly
from what came out of the the summit
from this past we took our guidance from
that so we're staying on that and on the
task uh um of ultimately uh addressing
balance
billing
yes okay question
yes the study would assume that all uh
payers paid the same rate I believe um
could you that's a little bit different
than what we were talking about uh no I
think it it it's the same as what we
were talking about um
if
um if the cost of providing Services
were defined in a way that
um took into account uh the fact that
certain payers don't pay costs up to
that cost level um then the notion of
you know cost based reimbursement for
the commercial payers they're only 10%
of the market would be
like absurdly
inflated
um uh I worked out a little mathematical
example of what that might mean but um
just in support of this idea that cost
Bas reimbursement has to be well let me
just back up and say that um one of the
fire chiefs who participated in the
summit would frequently just talk about
um his cost in terms of the overall
operating costs
um uh divided by the number of services
they provide per year um and that
results in a single number which is
their cost regardless of who the payer
is so we're taking a similar approach to
that um and I'm also saying that it um
cost based uh reimbursement um doesn't
really make sense if you have to take
into account that certain payers are not
up to that level just quick followup
further question um so out of the study
yesterday or the day before yesterday
was uh we were talking about 325 per of
Medicare for for the uh the commercial
the two commercial payers that we had
right um this study isn't going to give
give us a magic number of 325 or
whatever it should be we'll have we'd
have to take the results of the study
and then sort of do some calculations
outside of the scope of this is that
right if actually we are asking the
actual expert to um provide us with this
illustrative um Statewide rate schedule
which can be compared to Medicare so we
in fact they're allowed
to uh illustrate that a luster rate
schedule as a percent of Medicare if if
they feel that's it's
appropriate but it but it won't it be it
won't be prescriptive of what the payers
should pay to make up for the lack of
Medicare funding right that it would be
in an all-payer system um and it would
be treating everyone equally basically
right and there is such a thing that
some states that it requires a federal
waiver um of Medicare and Medicaid um
but there are a few states that have all
payer systems in which all payers pay
the same rate for uh specified
service that's the
goal that's that's what we're trying to
get to so to make this
Fair okay so this is yes repres
spear you have a date of December 31st
2024 the end of this year to get this
report out what's the risk on that of
not meeting the deadline of making
it um that certain of us will suffer a
deadline um I feel confident enough yes
uh with the way it's set up that that we
okay representative M thank you Mr
chairman thank you so much for putting
this together Alex um what's the
relative what what's approximately the
the cost of this and the reason I ask is
I'm I'm wor this is going to finance
right this is going to finance so that's
a little B so let them worry about that
well that's kind of exactly my
worry uh is that we we risk no we do
have the money that's in this bill it's
going to be funded through the healthare
fund okay so we have the money all
finances has to do is agree to allocate
the money and and and budgetarily
process it but there we do have the
money this is not coming out of General
funds to pay for this study so the
chairman feels there's relatively low
risk that they would say we don't have
the money and you just pass all these
bills that are unfunded and you can't do
your pay and
study May can I turn my mic off and tell
you what I think about
Finance no I'm I'm I'm I'm really I'm
really asking because I I guess my
followup is could there was there was
some informal discussion about
maybe
uh G collecting this
data over the course of a a year or two
and sunsetting and then having the
industry basically live with the results
like the the Real Results you know
putting in a
number whether it's you know 150 200 325
like other states or whatever and then
collect the real data and then that's
the number so the data is um we are
looking back this is going to look back
so it's not you know we're not we're not
creating new data so we're looking back
at it and um and the subcommittee felt
that this is the right way to
go so could not not to try to go ahead
and pass numbers and sunset it and and
then having the angst of changing the
system at that point based upon new
numbers that we think the best answer is
for us to spend a little time do this in
a an orderly process I mean to be frank
I thought that we were going to get
something like this right out after the
summit met anyways I was surprised to
you know that see the bill that came
over from the Senate because that's not
what what we were expecting so we since
we heard from Alex 325 number being
close to reasonable in customer
yesterday that's what I understood now
right now let's you know it we're if if
you want to debate the other Bill and
turn turn this down and take up another
one um you know that's your OPP your
opportunity to do that because this is
the subcommittee right now and you on
the subcomittee that's not that's not
what I'm suggesting I'm I'm just saying
could could we accomplish the same thing
and provide some more immediate relief
or so if we if we do the do the the
study committee bill or the study bill
and it comes back in December new
legislation then it's effective so it's
we're looking like what about a year
year and a half out before effective
year delay no matter what year and a
half it's a year but in the end of the
day that's the appropriate way to do
these things you don't you don't you
don't give some money I mean I know in
your mind that this is that that this is
critical that they get money right away
but I would bet venture to say that when
you were here 20 years ago you heard the
same issues back then that how how they
were underfunded a ambulance companies
were struggling then too correct
okay yes representative Pell so the
completion the end ofe completion date
is really contingent on being able to
get the data so do you feel that the
requirements under um section one Roman
numeral one are sufficient to make sure
that you get the data by from the
ambulance companies do you feel that's
yes the um the safety commissioner has
the authority to set the due date um and
it will have to be fairly
aggressive it'll have to be fairly
aggressive to get all this data yes and
this also provides that that due date
gets worked out collaboratively with the
insurance commissioner who's going to be
more familiar with the whole project
plan right um but it will have to be
aggressive in order to make I assume
they High motivated to do it hopefully
yeah representative
spear I think I was going to say the
same thing it seems to me if we want to
make any movement on this it would
behoove the ambulance companies to get
on board and get us the data so we could
get something good out as soon as
possible she's replacing Gibs yeah okay
all right so uh representative hunt
second by representative brw moves ought
to pass on amendment number 1641 any
discussion on the amendment
see none all those in favor please raise
your hand one two three four five no
not oh he oh no I didn't I didn't have
collabor on here okay okay okay six to
nothing it's six to nothing okay oh I
didn't even notice that there we go
great okay uh represent hunt second by
represent Bur moves ought to pass as
amended any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor please
raise your hand 1 two 3 four five six
vote six zip and exec uh subcommittee
work session is adjourned now we'll open
up the public uh the executive session
uh and the first bill up and the only
Bill is Senate Bill
407 uh and I will move the process along
um I actually you're doing this one now
yeah yeah okay so representative hunt
second by representative buroughs moves
ought to pass on amendment number
[Music]
amendment okay seeing none the clerk
remember that okay so wait a minute yeah
you got a lot of names to change yeah
just you do it when you get to it
okay um representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes yes
yes
ra
Yes Yes
W yes yes yes
no Gibbs no Gibbs no
Gibbs no Gibbs no Gibbs no Gibbs we have
no we have no Replacements today
rights yes oh
sorry um
Carrie
yes we're in the voting mode all right
yes you missed me you missed
me representative P
yes's to go I thought I heard she
checked
you yes okay all right see know this
confus me because I have a raptor here
there you go you do
have so that's that's yes he's
yes got it got it got it and
yes 17 okay the motion carries voted 17
is zip representative hunt second by
representative burough moves ought to
pass as
motion representative am yes
yes post yes Cole yes M yes belli yes
ton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
yes M
yes spear yes
solivan grassy yes Raptor yes chairman H
yes
you all those in favor of placing on the
consent calendar say
I those supposed so moved unanimously
good
for